bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant une table ronde sur le
modèle économique des stades cette table
ronde est organisée dans le cadre de la
mission commune d'information sur le
sport professionnels et les
collectivités territoriales alors
quelles sont les retombées économiques
d' un stade au niveau local quelle doit
être la part de financement public
toutes les réponses à ces questions et
beaucoup d'autres dans la table ronde
qui suit mesdames et messieurs
bonjour chers collègues donc après avoir
auditionner l'ensemble des associations
d'élus
locaux la mission commune d'information
sur le sport professionnel et les
collectivités souhaitent maintenant
examiner plus précisément la question
des stades et de de leur modèle
économique ce sujet est revenu à de
nombreuses reprises lors de nos
auditions contenu en particulier de la
maisaventure qu'on pu connaître des
villes comme Leem Grenoble ou
Istre la situation difficile dans
laquelle se retrouve donc ces
collectivités est au cœur de notre
problématique puisqu'elle illustre de
manière spectaculaire le caractère
déséquilibré des relations qui peuvent
aujourd'hui exister entre les clubs
professionnels et les collectivités
territoriales
soumise à la pression de l'opinion
publique à la nécessité de favoriser le
développement local aux normes
qu'élaborent les fédérations ou les
ligues les collectivités territoriales
sont souvent obligés d'aborter leur
concours financiers pour l'entretien la
rénovation ou même la construction de
nouveaux
équipements les sommes enjeux sont
souvent considérables de l'ordre de
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
si l'on considère par exemple le coût
total des nouveaux stades en incluant le
coût des infrastructures environnantes
qui reste à la charge des collectivités
territoriales or si les coûts sont bien
là il en demeure des incertitudes sur le
retour sur investissement en particulier
au bénéfice de l'économie locale devant
l'émergence d'un nouveau modèle
économique du sport professionnel
inspiré notamment d'expériences
étrangères comme celle de l'Allemagne où
les clubs sont propriétaires de leur
infrastructure et le valorisent grâce à
l'organisation de compétition et des
vêements il nous est apparu nécessaire
de mieux comprendre les évolutions en
cours pour identifier les tendances et
si possible discerner les bonnes
pratiques quel bilan peut-on faire des
différents régimes juridiques
disponibles concession délégation de
services public partenariat public privé
faut-il favoriser la propriété des
grands équipements par les clubs
professionnels est-il devenu nécessaire
de plafonner le montant de la
participation publique ça a été abordé
plusieurs fois dans nos auditions dans
le cadre des financements des grands
équipements faut-il par exemple prévoir
une étude systématique de la Direction
générale des collectivités locales
concernant les grands projets
d'équipements sportifs pour mieux
évaluer la portée des enjeux et des
engagements
financiers il a été aussi abordé le
l'aléa sportif qui est souvent est
sous-estimé euh et comment donc la
question et comment peut-on aider les la
collectivité et les collectivités
territoriales à prendre une décision qui
est suffisamment éclairée par rapport à
cette aléas sportif et combient-il donc
là aussi d'obliger les clubs à intégrer
cet aléa sportif euh dans les prévision
budgétaire travailler avec les clubs
lors de la reconstruction ou la
construction de nouveaux
équipements concernant plus
particulièrement aussi les collectivités
territoriales et pouréquilibrer les
rapports avec les clubs professionnels
fautil faut-il désigner un chef de fil
euh qui pourrait être soit une métropole
soit la la région pour piloter la
construction de nouveau grands
équipements euh afin avec trois
objectifs hein de pour essayer de cibler
ces ces collectivités d'abord s'assurer
d'une bonne expertise de la collectivité
que la collectivité puisse avoir une
bonne expertise de l'enjeu d'un nouvel
équipement avoir aussi euh de s'assurer
que la collectivité qui est en charge de
porter ces grands équipement et la
capacité aussi à disposer de la surface
financière nécessaire en cas de coup dur
et aussi de s'intégrer et d'intégrer ces
nouveaux projets dans dans un maillage
harmonieux des équipements au niveau des
territoires voici quelques-unes des
questions que nous avons à l'esprit et
qui ne sont pas limitatives puisque nous
pourrions aussi aborder la question du
rôle de l'État dans le pilotage des
grands équipements le débat sur un
nouveau grand stade en Île-de-France
voulu par la féd ftion française du
rugby la préparation de l'Euro 2016 et
le rôle de l'UEFA qui qui détermine de
nombreuses normes pour les stades qui
pénalisent aussi là et qui donnent des
contraintes supplémentaires aux
collectivités enfin je rappelle que
notre mission ne rendra ses travaux
qu'au printemps et que ces propositions
ont aussi pour objectif d'alimenter le
débat sur le projet de loi de
programmation sur le sport qui est
attendu pour début 2014 pour évoquer
l'ensemble de ces questions donc nous
avons réuni aujourd'hui plusieurs
personnalités ayant des profils
différents et complémentaires donc je
vrais remercier pour leur présence
monsieur jean-pcal gaillant économiste
du sport professeur à l'université
d'humaine monsieur étien tê conseiller
régional de ronalpe et Conseiller
Municipal de
Lyon Monsieur Alain calderala directeur
général de l'océan Stadium du
HAVRE merci Monsieur Damien Rajot
directeur opérationnel de VC Stadium et
Monsieur Jean-Michel olas président de
l'Olympique Lonis et qui est accompagné
aussi de son directeur général donc mes
messieurs je mes messieurs je vous
proposis donc d'achever notre table
ronde vers les entre 17h et
17h30 et donc je vous propose de pour
commencer de laisser la parole à nos
intervenant pour 5 à 7 minutes en leur
laissant la possibilité soit de vous
exprimer de votre place soit de de venir
au
pupitre après quoi je laisserai la
parole à notre
rapporteur Stéphane Mazard qui aura
aussi lui une une série de questions à à
poser aux intervenants vous pourrez donc
à ce moment lui répondre et et réagir
hein brièvement au débat et bien sûr
l'ensemble des des sénateurs sont aussi
invité à à poser différentes questions à
leur tour donc je vous rappelle que nos
débats sont filmés et diffusés en direct
sur Internet et qu'un live tweet est
organisé sur le compte officiel du Sénat
Sénat direct je laisse tout de suite la
parole pour débuter à Monsieur
Jean-Pascal gaayant
merci pour un bassin économique local
les retombées économiques d'une grande
infrastructure ou d'une grande
manifestation sportive sont
essentiellement engendré par les
dépenses des spectateurs non locaux
c'est-à-dire des spectateurs étrangers à
ce bassin économique en effet seul ces
dépenses constituent une injection nette
de ressources dans la zone géographique
considérée génér génératrice d'un
surcroix d'activité dans le cas des
stades accueillant les rencontres des
championnats professionnels de football
de rugby de handball de basketball ces
dépenses consenti par les spectateurs
non locaux sont faibles à l'inverse de
ce qui se passe pour certains événements
ponctuels à retentissement international
comme les Jeux Olympique la Coupe du
Monde ou Championnat d'Europe de
football un tournoi de tennis du
grandchelem ou une grande course
automobile en dehors de l'accueil de
telles manifestations les retombées
économiques au sens strict d'un stade
sont très limités certes la présence
d'un stade génère un petit socle
d'emploi lié à l'administration
l'entretien la sécurité du stade et
l'existence d'une équipe professionnelle
résidente est synonyme de présence d'une
entreprise pouvant compter plusieurs
dizaines de salariés à proximité de
l'infrastructure mais il illusoire de
penser que l'édification d'un stade peut
en soi être un investissement à Ha
rendement ce qui pousse les villes à
construire et rénover les stades est
sans doute l'espoir d'une rentabilité
immatérielle rentabilité par le biais de
l'image de marque de l'aire urbaine et
rentabilité sociale par le biais de
l'identification des résidents à
l'équipe sportive usagère de l'enceinte
d'autre part pour l'un ou pour l'autre
de ces bénéfices immatériels la
quantification s'avère un exercice
difficile source de débat sans fin
mais puisque de tels bénéfices existent
il semble justifier qu'un stade puisse
être financé en partie par les
collectivités
territoriales le financement public des
stades me semble être indissociable de
la préservation d'une spécificité
européenne des ligues de sport
professionnel le principe d'un système
de promotion et relégation ce système
garantit l'ancrage géographique des
clubs et permet à toute ville d'accéder
au plus haut division national par un
système de promotion au mérit sportif
ainsi la commune de boulasac 6937
habitants est-elle parvenue à atteindre
l'élite du basket français en 2012-23 ou
la commune de guingan 7280 habitants
est-elle revenue pour une 8e saison au
sein de l'élite du football français en
août 2013 cette possibilité de promotion
mérite sportif semble être un principe
auquel est vicéralement attaché le
citoyen français pour paraphraser la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen le citoyen semble spectateur
semble attaché à l'idée de ce que les
clubs naissent et demeurent libr et égau
en droit cette dimension est à mes yeux
un point fondamental du débat en effet
le système de promotion relégation est
aussi et c'est le rever de la médaille
le système qui insécurise les
entreprises que sont les clubs de sport
professionnel comme le note le très
instructif rapport du Sénat sur le
financement public des grandes
infrastructures du 17 octobre 2013 une
limitation du pourcentage de clubs
relégués en division inférieure pour
être une réponse à approprié à la menace
que fait peser sur la pérennité des
clubs l'alléa sportif mais alors la
légitimité du financement public des
stades en serait d'autant diminué cette
dimension se retrouve également dans les
options que choisissent les Lig pour
favoriser soit un modèle à l'espagnol où
Barcelone et et Madrid dominent
outrageusement une ligue très
déséquilibrée soit un modèle français ù
ces dernières années en tout cas
l'incertitude sur l'identité du
vainqueur était très grande six
champions différents ont été sacrés ces
six dernières années en effet par une
répartition ciblée des droits TV et par
l'absence de mécanisme de restauration
de l'équilibre compétitif la Ligue peut
favoriser l'émergence de quelques Titans
qui trusteront indéfiniment les titres
ou à l'inverse favoriser l'équité par
des plafonds salariaux ou une
répartition des droits de diffusion
visant à compenser les écarts de
recettes au guichet ou revenus de
merchandising il me semble là encore que
la légitimité du financement public est
d'autant plus grande que le système
donne sa chance à chacun en dépit de
prédisposition inégale liée à la taille
des aires urbaines ou à la présence de
mescèes généreux on objectera que le
financement public des stade étant
essentiellement local et non national ce
financement s'inscrit dans une logique
de compétition entre territoires
l'argument est pertinent mais il ne
faudrait pas qu'une telle compétition
construise à une surconstruction de
grand en stade financé par l'argent
public conduisant nécessairement au
gaspillage social que représente
l'existence d'enceintes récentes
inutilisées comme celle de Grenoble du
Man ou de Sedan en résumé il existe une
position du curseur que doit fixer
chaque ligue de sport professionnel
entre deux positions extrêmes la Ligue
fermée sur le modèle nord-américain dans
laquelle le financement public des
stades semble totalement illégitime et à
l'opposé la ligue avec promotion et
relégation et mécanisme favorisant
l'équilibre compétitif dans laquelle une
part de financement public substantiel
paraît légitime ce choix préalable doit
être clair et assumer si une ligue
organisatrice assume clairement le choix
d'une ligue ouverte la prénance la
présence d'un financement public est
légitime mais il convient de limiter la
part de ce financement car le sport
professionnel est aussi et demeure un
spectacle commercial il est difficile de
fonder économiquement la part maximale
de financement public qu'il faudrait
légalement imposer un tel travail
nécessiterait une évaluation en terme de
welfare engendré par la présence d'un
club de sport professionnel dans un
bassin économique local la littérature
en économie du sport professionnel est
encore balbuciante sur la question du
bien-être éprouvé par les committed fans
les supporteurs et les uncommitted fans
les spectateurs les autres spectateurs
neutres le seuil de maximal de
financement public devrait être selon
moi modulable fixé au regard du
pourcentage d'équipes reléguées par
exemple 50 % maximum de financement
public si 15 % des équipes sont
reléguées et seulement 16,66 % de
financement public si seulement 5 % des
équipes sont
reléguées pour terminer mon intervention
je voudrais resserrer mon propos sur la
question du modèle économique des stades
au sens plus strict du terme j'ai dit
plus haut qu'il est illusoire de penser
que l'édification d'un stade peut en
soit être un investissement de à haut
rendement ce propos doit être nuancé en
observant les exemples étrangers
allemands comme vous l'avez dit ou
américains en particulier un stade peut
certainement devenir une zone de vie et
d'activité beaucoup plus substantielle
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui dans la
plupart des villes françaises encore
faut-il que la venue des spectateurs au
stade s'inscrive dans une optique de
divertissement familial ceci nécessite
des tarifs plus accessibles de manière
systématique un environnement apaisé par
l'exclusion des spectateurs agressifs et
outranciers et une stabilité réelle des
horaires de match
il est là encore question de beurre et
d'argent du beurre une ligue ne peut pas
à la fois saucissonner ses journé en un
maximum de tranches horaires pour
obtenir les plus forts droits TV et
espérer fidéliser les spectateurs avec
des horaires abracad enantex et
fluctuant on rappelle qu'en 2012 pour ne
pas concurrencer la retransmission d'un
match de Ligue 1 le vendredi soir les
matchs de Ligue 2 ont été décalé à 18h
puis à la suite d'un concert de
protestation à 18h45 entraînant une
chute de fréquentation Ligue 2 de 10 à
20 % enfin il sera sûrement question
dans cette table ronde de la forme
juridique des dispositifs permettant au
collectivité territoriale de participer
en toutou parti au financement des
stades et en particulier quand elles en
deviennent les propriétaires n'étant pas
juriste je me contenterai simplement
d'approuver pleinement et d'appuyer la
très pertinente recommandation du
rapport d'information du Sénat
précédemment cité la lourdeur de ces
investissements de long terme et la
glorieuse incertitude du sport devrait
conduire les futurs propriétaires à
évaluer sérieusement la rentabilité de
la nouvelle enceinte dans un scénario
résolument pessimiste je vous remercie
de votre
attention merci beaucoup monsieur Gayant
je passe tout de suite la parole à
Monsieur Étienne t conseiller régional
de ronalp et Conseiller Municipal de
Lyon merci pour aborder cette question
plusieurs questions évidemment se posent
aux collectivités et la première
question qui s'est posée
elle est sur le plan économique c'est
est-ce qu'il y a un avantage économique
en matière d'emploi sur la présence d'un
grand stade et d'un grand club de foot
et comme le disait la Cour des comptes
on n'a pas mis en évidence de façon
significatif c'est plus une croyance
qu'une démonstration peu d'études
existent à à mon sens et on a pu par
exemple étudier à partir tout étant
relatif bien sûr comme analyse des
palmarès économiques et emplois publiés
dans des grandes revues comme L'Express
le challenge ou autres qui classent les
villes avec Nant en tête par exemple
pour le dernier classement et classe une
cinquantaine de villes et on a voulu
comparer pour voir s'il y avait une
corrélation bien entendu avec les
résultats sportifs des clubs sportifs
professionnels et on a pris comme
critère par exemple sur les 10 dernières
années le taux de présence en Ligue 1 on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a 35 clubs qui sont
présents en Ligue 1 hors Paris puisque
Paris ne fait pas partie de l'analyse
il y en a seulement 20 qui sont dans les
50 et quand on fait comme sur les plans
statistiques un nuage de points le nuage
de point ne démontre aucune pertinence
de la présence de clubs sporttif
professionnels de Ligue 1 sur les 10
dernières années comme c'est démontré
donc on est effectivement plutôt dans la
croyance et il y a bien entendu de
nombreux contre-exemples on sait très
bien qu'une des régions qui a capable de
s'offrir deux clubs en Ligue 1 de façon
fréquente c'est la Corse on peut pas
dire que c'est le développement
économique en Corse et la grande chute
de l'économie de Saint-Étienne a été
corrélative à la grande période
également de
Saint-Étienne le deuxième élément
c'était de savoir si très directement
c'était créateur d'emploi et les
analyses économiques des commissions
régionales et cetera qui a une politique
d'évaluation à la région ronalp
s'intéresse évidemment au contenu en
emploi du chiffre d'affaires des
entreprises pour établir ses aides
pourquoi parce que évidemment chaque
fois qu'on fait du chiffre d'affaires il
y a forcément des retombées classiques
de TVA d'ursaf de caisse de retraite et
cetera or le football professionnel est
en moyenne aux environs de 1,8 2 3
emplois pour pour 1 million d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires alors que le BTP le
droit commun enfin les entreprises
communes sont plutôt aux alentours de 7
à 8 emplois ce qui veut dire que
lorsqu'un
ménage fait un choix économique de dire
quel est mon mon choix de loisir est-ce
que je vais aller au cinéma au
restaurant ou voir un un sport
professionnel comme le foot est-ce que
je crée plus d'emploi ou je crée moins
d'emploi et d'une certaine manière
chaque fois que un ménage fait le choix
d'aller au foot il détruit des emplois
plus plus qu'il n'en crée la troisième
question qui s'est évidemment posée
c'est est-ce que la
croissance de la grosseur des stades
c'est-à-dire plus on met de place estce
qu'on aura de plus en plus de
billetteries qui va nous permettre de
payer le stade est-ce que la billetterie
générée par la grandeur du stade est en
capacité euh de de financer ces stades
alors je crois que les chiffres sont
connus mais on peut les redonner le la
le grand vecteur de recette à plus de 50
% c'est les droits de retransmission
télé qui se sont apparus avec deux
marches d'escalier significatives 2000
et 2004 très significatif qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui presque Ligue 1 Ligue 2
confondu c'est plus de 700 millions
d'euros sur l'ensemble des clubs et ça
représente pour beaucoup de clubs plus
de 50 %. donc la première recette n'est
pas les la billetterie la billetterie
représente 10 15 20 % pour l'Olympique
Lyonnais sur une moyenne un peu près de
20 million d'euros on peut voir d'abord
la la sensibilité hein on verra après
mais aujourd'hui on est à 17 12 millions
si on prend on voit bien que ce n'est
pas avec la croissance de cette
billetterie à combien même il y aurait
des places plus chères plus plus VIP
plus ceci qu'on peut espérer financer
des stades dont les montants sont de 300
à 400 millions d'euros donc c'est pas
dans la billetterie qu'il faut espérer
pouvoir
trouver les stades surtout qu'on est
confronté je crois comme on le dit à
l'aléa du sport et à la difficulté de de
ces aspects on on est confronté au fait
que si on veut remplir un stade plus
grand il faut qu'il y ait un plus beau
spectacle c'est-à-dire il faut
effectivement que euh il y ait des
joueurs qui attirent et qui fassent des
résultats et il est loin d'être évident
que les recettes générées par la
grandeur d'un stade qui elle-même
engendre des dépenses générées par la
qualité des joueurs aboutissent euh à
financer le stade par les billetteries
et les effets indirects on le voit bien
sûr dans le cas de l'Olympique Lyonnais
où la baisse de qualité des des joueurs
puisqu'on vend de plus en plus de
joueurs à Lyon à aboutit très
logiquement au fait que le club n'est
plus aussi champion qu'il l'a été dans
le passé conttenu de de ces aspects-l
donc la difficulté après se pose
évidemment l'intervention et la
légitimité des collectivités locales et
la grande difficulté c'est par rapport
aux aides économiques qui sont
interdites ou réglementées par la
Commission européenne comme le souligner
le dernier rapport sénatorial l'ensemble
des aides économiques qui sont loin
d'être négligeables dans l'opération
Euro 2016 n'ont toujours pas été validé
par l'Europe tout au moins à la date
d'octobre de ce ratport nont toujours
pas été validé et elles ne sont pas
négligeables car il n'y a pas de vrai
stade comme vous l'avez indiqué qui soit
100 % privé même le plus privé des
stades de France tel qu'il est annoncé a
des aidees publi qui sont connu les 20
millions d'euros plus une garantie
d'emprunt du conseil général plus de la
Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation plus
tous les équipements évidemment
périphériques donc il se pose la
problème dans un système où ce sont des
sociétés commerciales qui sont côté en
bourse de la légitimité de cette aide on
sait que les lois buffet ont dû être
validé par l'Europe et on sait par
ailleurs que la concurrence est forte au
niveau européen quand on prend le
rapport bison qui soulignait à juste
titre des études qui avaient été faites
sur la corrélation qu'il y a entre le
poids fin ci du club et sa réussite
sportive en Champions League
c'est-à-dire en ligue européenne et bien
il y avait une corrélation directe pour
le cout même principe des nuages de
points et statistiqu il y avait une
corrélation directe qui était faite à à
ce niveau-là et donc aider un club c'est
lui donner plus de chance d'être
européen c'est donc d'être dans la
concurrence concurrence européenne alors
effectivement se pose toujours et c'est
le dernier point PE peut-être de cette
première présentation
euh c'est de de se dire mais pourquoi
une grande agglomération Lyonais même si
le débat n'est pas le l'agglomération
lyonnaise mais on peut voir que le c
lilois est un peu particulier puisque
c'est un PPP mais le risque industriel
est aussi pris par la ville puisque le
contrat tel que je l'ai vu avant
signature s'il a pas changé si la le
club descend en Ligue 2 la collectivité
diminue de 50 % sa redevance donc qui a
un risque industriel pris par les
collectivités en ce qui concerne le
stade de Lyon le le mécanisme est
différent sur la participation des
collectivité car lorsqu'il évidemment
annoncé la possibilité avec le nouveau
stade dans les documents officiels de
faire 70 à 100 millions d'euros de
recette supplémentaires par an c'est
évidemment pas par la billetterie et si
ce n'est pas par la billetterie c'est
par autre chose en fait
and car c'est pas un cl c'est une
ensemble d'opérations sur une
cinquantaine d'étar qui s'est faite par
la session à un prix selon nous en
dessous de la valeur du marché mais
c'est un débat juridique qui n'est pas
clos donc on le dit simplement selon
nous qui va permettre un ensemble de
plus-value financière en revendant les
droits à construire pour un certain
nombre de bureau et permettre le
financement de ce stade parce que quand
on regarde l'ensemble des grands clubs
les toujours sur la base de la
billetterie euh qui a pu être donnée
aucun grand club un peu près comparable
ne peut générer plus de 50 millions
d'euros de billeterie par an à à ce
niveau-là et nous les préconisations que
nous faisons euh je pense que la
première chose c'est pas qu'il ne manque
de l'argent dans le club sport dans les
clubs sportifs professionnels au
contraire ils sont très riches mais ça a
été non pas de l'huile dans les rouages
pour faire fonctionner mais de l'huile
sur le feu pour emballer les prix et
notamment les prix des joueurs c'est de
faire ce qui s'est fait dans d'autres
d'autres groupes sportifs he c'est de
limiter euh le plafonnement du nombre de
joueurs de la valeur absolue des
dépenses et de masse salariale et et
aussi en valeur relative mais je pense
que c'est pas la valeur relative le plus
utile c'est donc un plafonnement global
des joueurs pour éviter l'emballement
des classes sportifes
professionnelles merci beaucoup monsieur
quel
deral je rappelle qui est directeur
général de l'océen Stadium du Havre donc
moi je vais être un peu plus pragmatique
puisque quelque part on se pose des
questions de suite lorsqu'on parle d'un
stade mais personne se pose des
questions quand on quand on crée une
salle des fêes quand on crée un palais
des congrès donc je je pense qu'après il
faut voir ce qui en est fait nous
l'objectif alors que je suis quand même
une filiale à 100 % d'un club de foot
c'était justement d'éviter d'être
dépendant de l'alléa sportif l'objectif
du stade ce n'est pas que d'être un
stade pour le foot mais un stade pour
tous donc l'objectif d'un stade pour
tous ça veut bien dire qu'on sera pas
qu'avec notre club résident mais qu'on
va organiser d'autres choses dans le
stade on organise des concerts il y a
peu de temps vous avez vu la Fédération
Française de Rugby qui jouait chez nous
l'objectif c'est de démultiplier nos
activités pour pouvoir être un centre de
vie donc à la construction ce qui a été
judicieux c'est que on va dire le club a
été intégré directement par la
communauté des agglomérations avrez et
qui a permis de déployer un dispositif
qui soit pas que figé que sur le foot
c'est qu'on fait aussi bien des
séminaires donc ça évite peut-être à
terme d'avoir à créer d'autres Palais
des Congrès donc c'est d'avoir un
investissement judicieux qui permettent
à la collectivité d'avoir un équipement
qui soit utile tout le temps et qui soit
ouvert 24h/ 24 365 jours par an donc
c'est certain le foot c'est notre club
résident c'est 19 dates mais si vous
regardez notre calendrier l'année
dernière on a fait 27 dates au total
dont si dates on va dire et sportive et
culturelle puisqu'on a fait un concert
on déploie un concert cette année on
fait des séminaires tous les jours on a
des séminaires donc l'objectif c'est ne
pas de se restreindre co foot ou Co
àallé allé à sportif parce qu'on peut
parler aussi bien du rugby ou du basket
mais de diversifier notre
offre donc après on s'est créé donc ce
panel de multiactivités et pourtant on
n'est pas je dire un pppiste puisque
quelque part on est l'artisan à l'heure
actuelle ça été une volonté commune
entre le HAAC et et notre ville on
essaie de se démarquer par on va dire
un un calendrier de qualité et de donner
aussi bien un un vol social au stade
puisque quelque part on regarde aussi
l'économie locale on est conscient comme
vous le dites que quelque part le bassin
comme le disait monsieur gaayant le
bassin économique est restreint encore
plus au Havre puisque quand on regarde
on dit qu'en général en Ligue 2 les gens
si on parle de football viennent de 30
minutes et en Ligue 1 il peut faire une
heure de de déplacement si vous prenez
le Havre si on fait 30 minutes je fais
un cercle autour du stade avec le côté
de la mer j'ai pratiquement plus
personne qui viendra voir le stade donc
l'objectif c'est de de désacraliser le
monde du foot et d'organiser d'autres
choses quand il y a des activités je
pense que il y avait un précurseur dans
dans cela c'était le Stade Français qu'
faisait par magie qui vous faisait venir
bouger beaucoup de monde nous on essaie
de s'inspirer un petit peu de de de ce
qu'ils ont fait on essae à chaque match
de de créer une fête une diversité pour
que les personnes viennent avec un
objectif unique c'est de passer un bon
moment certes l'objectif c'est on sait
bien que beaucoup viennent pour voir le
spectacle et se dire ben c'est la
victoire de leur équipe nous c'est
essayer de justement ne pas être
contraint d'avoir un classement
exceptionnel pour pouvoir avoir du
public l'objectif c'est de se débattre
et de montrer que un stade ça peut vivre
mais pas qu'avec un club résident donc
moi c'est bref mais c'est plutôt
pragmatique et je pense que c'est une
pratique qui est un peu commune à ce que
font les PP pistes puisque quelque part
l'objectif c'est de rentabiliser
l'infrastructure
rentabiliser l'investissement qui a été
fait par la Collectiv
é merci je pense qu'on aura des
questions à vous poser notamment le
rapporteur monsieur Damien Rageot donc
qui est directeur opérationnel de V6
Stadium vous avez la parole bonjour euh
donc je je m'occupe de V6 Stadium qui
est une structure qui est récente hein
qui a été développée
euh il y a 2 ans créé il y a 2 ans dans
le but essentiel d'essayer de mettre en
place et de développer un modèle
économique pour les enceintes ou euh 20
26 concessions euh à départ dans
l'actionnariat de d'une structure qui
gère un stade donc aujourd'hui on est
euh présent naturellement au Stade de
France mais également euh au mm Arena
euh à l'alliance Riviera récemment
inauguré au stade de Bordeaux et puis au
projet d'Arena de
d'unquerque qui est une salle de
pratiquement 10000 places du type salle
qu'on peut voir euh aux États-Unis euh
le sujet est est assez complexe à vrai
dire parce
que il y a une vraie volonté de de
développer une économie c'est nécessaire
on est là avant tout dans une structure
parce qu'on a répondu à une demande de
la ville d'une d'un concédant pour
construire d'abord un stade et puis
après pour
participer au financement et à
l'exploitation du stade sur des bases où
on voit bien que le modèle du sport est
à une charniè en ce moment en tout cas
sur le marché français où on il y a
nécessité à le à le développer et à
peut-être faire évoluer certaines
frontières parce que forcé de constater
que aujourd'hui si les clubs de foot
notamment non ne se sont pas
propriétaires de leur stade à 100 % il y
a la première initiative qui va arriver
avec l'Olympique Lyonnais c'est que
peut-être le modèle économique ne le
permettait pas de le faire ou ne permet
pas de le faire et quand on pose cette
question là on regarde et c'est le
travail que j'essaie de faire et
j'étais assez séduit par ce que vous
avez dit il y a quand même plein de
facteurs qui font que c'est pas simple
de créer de l'argent aujourd'hui autour
d'un stade et donc pour un club
également c'est pas simple parce qu'il y
a différentes règles il y a
naturellement les règles liées au
sportifs avec le fameux alléas sportif
qui fait que ça rassure pas des gens qui
ont envie naturellement de des
entreprises extérieures de d'aider
d'apporter de l'argent parce que il y a
des incertitudes qui sont complexes je
pense que en France notre championnat
français on il y a des il y a trois
équipes qui descendent dans d'autres
championnats européens il y a moins
d'équipes ça a été souligné dans le dans
le rapport donc il y a moyen je pense de
pondérer un peu cette notion d'aller à
sportif d'une manière ou d'une autre le
deuxième point je pense qui est
important c'est et qui pour moi est le
clé de la réussite de nos futures
infrastructures c'est que je pense que
euh on sait aujourd'hui le fait d'avoir
des nouvelles infrastructures il va y
avoir une vraie réflexion derrière pour
créer du contenu et avoir une vraie
vision vis-à-vis du spectateur et c'est
le débat de fond c'est que je pense que
de manière peut-être non comment
dire non voulu au départ mais le
spectacle sportif aujourd'hui il est
tourné vers le diffuseur parce que c'est
lui qui aujourd'hui est la mine
financière des structures sportives donc
ement c'est le diffuseur qui a dicté
certaines règles et certaines règles ça
va à l'encontre de ce que peut attendre
un spectateur et c'est ce qui peut
expliquer derrière qu'on a du mal
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à avoir des taux de
remplissage
identiques à d'autres pays il y a une il
y a un vrai sujet aujourd'hui de dire il
faut avant tout dans un premier
temps avoir une réflexion sur les
spectateurs pour que les gens reviennent
dans les stades c'est pas une fatalité
je crois que d'avoir des meilleures des
meilleurs
infrastructures ça permet si on arrive
derrière à fidéliser et à mettre des
services ça permet d'amener des des
nouveaux spectateurs on voit les
premiers résultat du stade de Nice ils
sont excellents de l'Alliance
Riviera le tout est derrière d'avoir une
vraie politique avec ces spectateurs là
et là je pense qu'on a pas encore
franchi le pas on prend souvent pour
exemple ce qui se passe aux États-Unis
pour que les pour les spectateur c'est
le show avant match le show après match
ce qui les explications données autour
du du du spectacle on est loin de ça
aujourd'hui on a plus d'information
quand on est téléspectateur que quand on
est spectateur alors que quand on est
spectateur on a payé sa place donc il y
a quelque chose qu'il va falloir
renverser en terme de de de vision pour
créer de la valeur et cette valeur là
naturellement le club en bénéficiera et
l'exploitant derrière également donc moi
je pense que c'est le sujet numéro 1 et
force c'est de constater que ce travail
là il a pas été fait il a pas été
fait donc donc les habitudes je pense
sont sont sont pas n'ont pas encore
vraiment changé les incidents qui ont
lieu eu lieu récemment weekend dernier
sur un stade flamban neuf l'alliance
Rivéa qui est un stade superbe je pense
que c'est de la vie de tous les gens qui
l'ont visité c'est un stade qui répond
au au aux normes de l'Euro 2016 c'est
vraiment le stade on parle de lieu de
vie c'est le stade qui symbolise en tout
cas le lieu de vie avec des zones de
rencontrre pour que les spectateurs
puissent se croiser avec des espaces de
de restauration qui sont extrêmement
conviv
et puis on s'aperçoit qu'on est qu'on se
retrouve dans une une annonce médiatique
en tout cas t qu'elles ont été faites à
l'issue du match qui moi me font me vont
pas parce que je pense que la famille ne
s'y retrouve pas je pense que les gens
qui vont vouloir aller dans ces stad là
et ben ils vont prendre peur c'estàdire
que le monde sportif doit changer de
toute façon c'est c'est c'est c'est
indispensable par rapport à ça je pense
que le regard de vouloir attirer un plus
grand nombre dans les stades ça passe
aussi par des une relation différente
avec des des supporterurs qui ont des
agissements qui sont inacceptables dans
un
stade donc c'est pour terminer derrière
ça je pense qu'il y a pas de fatalité
euh à pas créer une économie certes on a
des difficultés hein dans notre secteur
d'activité mais mais il y a pas de
fatilité on regarde dans d'autres
secteurs d'économie si vous regardez le
cinéma la manière dont s'est développé
le cinéma en France avec les complexes
de cinéma qui ont certes décentraliser
le cinéma en centreville avec un petit
peu moins de peut-être de de côté un
petit peu bucolique on va dire mais on
est devenu c'est devenu des centres
extrêmement actifs avec derrière
l'activation de commercialisation de
d'autres produits que le film je pense
que le le le les stades vont aller vers
ça mais pour ça il faut un peu de temps
et on est et ce qui est compliqué c'est
que le le sport est pas inscrit quoi
l'organisation du sport en France c'est
pas inscrit dans un temps
long il faut des résultats sportifs tout
de suite parce qu'il y a des enjeux qui
sont lourds l'alla sportif fait que on
est obligé de maintenir un niveau court
terme extrêmement fort et une structure
comme un stade c'est du temps long c'est
du temps long pour le financement c'est
du temps long pour l'exploitation c'est
du temps long pour mettre en place des
équipes formées c'est du temps long pour
avoir une relation avec les spectateurs
et ça il y a un décalage certainement et
c'est tout ça que je pense l'exploitant
peut pas régler tout le club je pense
euh a parfois des difficultés parce
qu'il est pris dans ses enjeux court
terme la collectivité se retrouve
également parfois euh dans des enjeux où
là il faut construire et et parfois
surinvestir par rapport à la structure
pour construire dans le long terme donc
on est vraiment là dans un sujet sur un
les diffuseurs sont complètement absents
de la discussion pour dire comment créer
de la valeur dans les stades et pour moi
ils doivent être autour de la table donc
vous voyez les entreprises également
dire un stade donner un nom à un stade
comme alliance l'a fait pour le stade de
Nice c'est très important pour la marque
alliance c'est c'est quelque part c'est
le stade également de cette marque là
vous c'est un nouvel acteur qui rentre
maintenant dans cette réflexion là je
pense que les agissements du qui ont eu
lieu ce weekend dernier on voit bien que
ça fait perdre de la valeur ça fait
perdre de la valeur pour tout le
monde donc voilà c'est ce que je voulais
dire c'est que c'est un écosystème qui
pour résumer où
le prendre que par la lorniette du club
ou que la lorgniette de l'exploitant de
la
collectivité ça suffit pas je crois que
moi je suis venu ici pour justement
faire prendre conscience que c'est le
modèle économique global du sport qu'il
faut arriver à reconstruire avec les
différentes instances
naturellement chantier oui mais
nécessaire donc je vais laisser la
parole à Monsieur jean-michelas donc le
président de l'olympiqueunet bien sûr
alle-y
président monsieur le Président Mesdames
Messieurs sénatrices
sénateurs j'avoue que c'est un privilège
de d'exposer en fait ce qui pourrait
être la synthèse de tout ce qui a été
dit tout en relevant que on est dans
l'examen d'une
innovation l'examen d'une analyse mais
qui doit déboucher sur nombre de
solutions pragmatiques et non pas sur
des idées passéistes quelquefois
d'ailleurs
complètement exposé au travers de dogmes
qui sont des dogmes du passé si le Sénat
s'intéresse au futur il doit comme tout
entrepreneur qui prend un certain nombre
de risques en imaginant l'avenir
différemment de ce qui a été le passé
tenir compte d'un monde qui est un monde
en changement et considérer que parce
que à un certain moment les conditions
n'étaient pas réalisées pour trouver la
solution à ce que l'on souhaite
développer sur le futur c'est considérer
que il y a plus rien à faire et qu'il
faut rester à sa place et ne jamais
prendre d'initiative donc en fait de
quoi parle-t-on on parle d'un sujet qui
n'est pas un sujet franco-français on
n'est pas dans une activité spécifique
on est dans un environnement
concurrentiel
européen mondial mais en l'occurrence
européen qui donne en terme de
benchmarking en terme d'innovation en
terme de futur des idées qui sont des r
idées non seulement réaliste mais qui
aujourd'hui permettent d'avoir des bases
statistiques qui sont pas des nuages de
point théorique qui sont des choses
concrètes qui fonctionnent ailleurs qui
ont fait l'objet de réalisation et
d'anticipation concrète sur des éléments
qui sont nouveaux quels sont ces
éléments nouveaux aujourd'hui le
football économique le football certains
l'appellent business je sais pas
peut-être pour essayer de créer une
distorsion d'image mais l'économie du
football est en train de changer l'UEFA
qui gère sur le plan
européen l'ensemble de l'organisation de
ce football a défini une règle qui est
une règle formidablement productive en
terme de valeur et on parle avant tout
de valeur quand on cherche des solutions
qui consistent c'està-dire que ce qui a
pu être mise en évidence
sur l'Espagne mais qui est en train de
se mettre en place en France de manière
identique sans que personne ne crie à un
certain nombre je dirais de dangers et
bien cette règle cette ces valeurs ont
défini l'UEFA à mettre en place un
financial fairplay qui pour la première
année en 2014 va permettre d'exclure les
gens qui ne respectent pas ces règles de
manière tout à fait concrète et
contrairement à ce que certains pensent
et pour être président de l'association
des clubs européens qui gère cette mise
en place du Financial fair playay et
pour l'avoir vérifier à l'UFA encore la
semaine dernière au cours d'un meeting
je peux vous assurer que l'UFA ira au
bout de ses intentions nous avions hier
avec certains d'entre vous présents dans
la salle une réunion sous la présidence
de Jean glavani sur le football durable
et on parle de football durable quand on
parle d'infrastructure sportive et bien
Janine fentino qui est le directeur
général de l'UFA a confirmé que les
dispositions qui doivent concourir à un
équilibre économique sans qu'il y ait
d'ailleurs d'abandon de créance ou qu'il
y ait
l'intervention complètement étonnante de
messen sur le plan de l'économie du
football allait aller à terme et mettre
en œuvre ce qui est fondamental pour
faire en sorte que d'une part on se
retrouve dans un fairplay fairplay ça
veut dire aussi non seulement économique
mais un fairplay concurrentiel un
fairplay sportif qui permette à tout le
monde et en fonction d'un certain nombre
de critères d'y arriver et puis un
fairplay qui fasse que et bien on n'est
pas à combler par un certain nombre de
mesenes
ou j'allais dire de collectivité
territoriale et je vais faire le point
le lien avec mon propos tout de suite
après pour que l'économie du football
devienne une économie stable alors soit
on ne fait rien soit on regarde ce qui
se fait ailleurs et puis on en tire en
fonction des caractéristiques de la
France un certain nombre d'idées qui
sont des idées non pas conservatrices
mais des idées d'avenir des idées sur
lesquelles l'objectif c'est quoi c'est
de faire en sorte de se rapprocher du
modèle qui fonctionne partout en Europe
en Allemagne l'Allemagne a saisi l'ORT
oppunité de la Coupe du monde 2006 pour
réhabiliter pour
construire des stades qui aujourd'hui
sont à 100 % plein c'est-à-dire que
l'alléa sportive dont tout le monde
parle il existe pas en Allemagne le
stade du dernier est plein à 100 % non
pas parce que comme par le passé on
estime que c'est la compétition qui crée
l'affluence mais parce que c'est
l'adhésion à un nouveau mode de vie on
l'a dit tout à l'heure il faut un espace
dédié au spectacle quel qu'il soit avec
un véritable lieu de vie des normes de
sécurité fantastique parce que
aujourd'hui ce que recherche dans un
monde économique troublé avec une
sociologie qui a beaucoup changé ce que
recherchent les familles ce que
recherche les gens qui viennent dans ce
spectacle ce sont bien sûr de la
convivialité bien sûr du spectacle qui
peut-être du football à un moment donné
mais aussi et surtout de la sécurité et
les propos de Damien tout à l'heure
l'ont excellemment
développé sachez qu'en
Allemagne avant la construction de ces
10 stades la moyenne de spectateurs donc
la moyenne je parle pas du haut et du
bas la moyenne éit de 24000 spectateurs
aujourd'hui elle est de 48000
spectateurs dans les 10 stades du premer
au dernier donc ce qui veut dire que on
est bien dans un modèle qui peut
fonctionner et qui fonctionne aussi en
Angleterre qui fonctionne au Danemark
Copenhague même système ça était le
premier à le faire avant les Anglais
avant les
Allemands que que sais-je le Danemark a
pas été toujours aussi suspecté d'avoir
des règles qui soi à part de nos
raisonnements européens donc je crois
qu'il faut faire confiance
d'abord à ce changement de business
model qui inspire deux choses c'est que
dans l'équilibre économique du football
européen du Financial fairplay ne sont
pas pris en compte les investissements
qui sont liés à la création de stade
pour permettre justement à des
investisseurs privés de venir se
substituer aux collectivités
territoriales et deuxièmement l'Académie
la formation qui se substitue en terme
de prix d'acquisition d'un certain
nombre de joueurs à cette flambée des
prix que je conteste aussi comme tout le
monde et bien de trouver une solution de
football durable dans un dans une
période dans un une durée qui fasse que
on puisse passer par ces périodes
transitoires alors j'ai entendu dire
évidemment collectivité territoriale ou
pas nous avons eu en 98 la Coupe du
monde et c'est vrai que le modèle qui a
été inspiré a été inspiré beaucoup par
l'intervention des collectivités
territoriales était-ce une bonne chose
une mauvaise chose je n'en sais rien
simplement ce que je sais c'est que
contrairement à l'Allemagne de 2006 qui
a su construire des structures privées
qui aujourd'hui fonctionnent et sont
rentables contrairement à ce qui a été
évoqué tout à l'heure je crois que le
Bayern de Munich Dortmund qui sont
propriétaires de leur stade annonce
cette année entre 50 et 100 millions de
be d'excellents brut d'exploitation
alors que le stade est intégré
complètement Arsenal qui a été critiqué
un peu comme nous le sommes aujourd'hui
puisqu'on part dans un nouveau modèle et
chaque fois qu'on part dans un nouveau
modèle il y a une suspicion fantastique
des traditionnels pour pas dire des
conservateurs Arsenal aujourd'hui a
réussi sa mutation l'émiré de Stadium
fonctionne il est plein tout le temps à
un moment donné on a dit oui oui mais
comme il investit dans le stade il peut
pas investi dans les joueurs il ne
réussira pas aujourd'hui arsenal est
premier du championnat anglais de la
première ligue et donc on est dans un
une interrogation qui consiste à savoir
si on peut trouver comme les autres pays
européens le modèle qui va permettre de
substituer à l'investissement public un
investissement privé et et donc si le
modèle qui est un modèle pour lequel il
y a toujours des aléas quand on est
entrepreneur comme je suis depuis 40 ans
évidemment comprend des risques à un
moment donné pour dans un changement et
une mutation économique technologique
sociologique fantastique faire en sorte
de démontrer que les choix qui sont
faits sont les bons choix et il n'y a
que ceux qui peuvent permettent ou qui
croi qui ont les convictions qui peuvent
démontrer la chose la chose la plus
facile c'est montrer le contraire en
partant de principe passéiste et de dire
ça ne marchera pas parce que et cetera
ou de dire mais c'est pas un projet
privé parce que il y a des
interventions le FNDS dote l'Euro 2016
au travers de décisions qui ont été
prises d'un certain nombre de
subventions
pourquoi là où le stade le plus
fonctionnellement et technologiquement
abouti qui est d'ailleurs construit
aussi avec Vincy n'aurait-il pas droit à
cette côe par de financement d'un euro
2016 bon je me souviens d'ailleurs
qu'Étienne tête avait longtemps dit que
l'euro serait jamais en France qui ne se
ferait jamais à Lyon aujourd'hui on y
est et le financement qui a été octroyé
évidemment va avoir j'en ai la
conviction tout à fait tout à fait
lieu dernier point peut-être sur le plan
je dirais de de cette Inter tion le
modèle change permet de substituer à des
aléas sportifs et des aléas de
sociologie des aléas économiques et un
benchmarking qui fonctionne ailleurs
c'est de savoir si on est capable en
France de faire la même chose et là on
peut pas d'un côté dire il faut pas que
les collectivités territoriales
s'embarquent à fond là-dedans et puis
quand un certain nombre de gens viennent
se substituer aux collectivité
territoriale pour essayer de démontrer
la validité du modèle on dit ça peut pas
marcher il y a une contradiction de fond
qui touche au dogme alors si en plus je
dirais on fait en sorte de gêner celui
qui prend le risque ou ceux qui prennent
le risque par un harcèlement de
procédure judiciaire qui retarde de 3
ans le modèle économique évidemment on
crée les conditions pour que ça soit
encore plus difficile que que cela ne
l'est dans un environnement qui est
stabilisé pour conclure je dirais que ce
que nous faisons à Lyon a en terme de
vertu
les vertus de correspondre au Financial
fairplay qui est un modèle économique
qui va s'appliquer à tous les grands
club à tous les pays et faire en sorte
non seulement de résoudre ce qui s'est
passé il y a quelques années
c'est-à-dire avec des distorsions de
concurrence financé par un certain
nombre de Mesen et
deuxièmement de faire en sorte de donner
une chance pour peu que le bassin de
population corresponde au modèle
économique qui est développé c'est là où
il y a un calibrage à faire chacun Le
Havre a fait quelque chose de formidable
avec une prise d'option je crois qu'il
faut il y a pas de modèle unique il y a
des principes qui concourent au fait que
les choses sont en train de changer et
que si on ne saisit pas l'opportunité
comme on l'a fait ou qu' on ne l'a pas
fait en 98 de manière totale et bien on
restera avec des
sous-équipements
sportifs en France et que là on a une
opportunité queon n' pas le droit de
louper alors qu'est-ce que nous avons
fait tout d'abord c'est un projet
d'agglomération Lyon c'est la deuxème
agglomération
lyonnaise aujourd'hui toutes les grandes
agglomérations européennes ont un stade
moderne pourquoi en vertu de principe
Lyon n'aurait pas le droit
d'avoir ce que tous les les autres
métropoles européennes ont deuxièmement
c'est un modèle unique c'estàdire qu'on
se substitue à la collectivité en
investissant contrairement à ce qui a
été dit
l'investissement public est consacré
uniquement à
l'approche et à la mise en œuvre de
transport en commun qui sont utilisés
365 jours par an par le public et non
pas uniquement ceux qui vont aller au
stade c'est des équipements qui sont
faits pour l'agglomération c'est un
projet d'agglomération la preuve c'est
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui quasiment
terminés alors que le stade commence
simplement à grandir donc on peut pas
dire qu'ils ont été faits pour le stade
puisqu'il fonctionne d'ors et déjà alors
que certains c'est vertuux à faire en
sorte que le stade ne se e
jamais dans l'approche qui a été évoquée
tout à l'heure en terme de benchmarking
européen je voulais dire un point qui
malheureusement n'est pas perçu par les
spécialistes c'est que 20 des plus
grands premiers clubs européens
c'està-dire les 20 qui en terme de
ranking en terme de classement sont
classés à l'UFA dans les 20 premiers
18 sont propriétaires de leur stade
pourquoi la France
ne pourrait pas contrairement à tous les
autres pays européens et qui réussissent
faire en sorte de concourir bah c'est ce
que nous avons essayé de faire et quand
on regarde l'Allemagne l'Allemagne avant
2006 était je crois 14e à l'indice UEFA
des Nations de football ils ont résolu
le problème d'infrastructure en faisant
appel essentiellement à des financements
privés et ils ont résolu en même
temps le le objectif sportif puisque
c'est aujourd'hui tant sur le plan de la
nation donc des associations équipe
d'Allemagne que sur les clubs les
meilleurs performeers en terme de
football donc tout ceci pour dire que
c'est une spirale positive
vertueuse il y en a marre de toujours
critiquer les gens qui prennent un
certain nombre d'initiatives qu'est-ce
qui concourt à au positionnement
formidable de ces projets là c'est pas
parce que les droits télé sont trop
importants j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
parler de 700 millions pour la France
c'est pas vrai c'est
620 mais savez-vous que nous sommes le
pays le plus faible en matière de
collection de en matière de collecte de
de droit TV et pourquoi on est le plus
faible parce qu'on a pas
d'infrastructure technique qu'est-ce qui
fait qu'on crée un modèle vertueux c'est
que on a un certain nombre de stades qui
sont des stades conviviaux qui sont
pleins qui donnent un beau spectacle qui
eux-mêm génèent des recettes
qui elle-même permettent de
développer des centres de formation de
qualité et d'acquérir un certain nombre
de joueurs à des conditions tout à fait
performantes et ainsi de générer un
spectacle qui se vend de plus en plus
les Anglais avec leurs stade privé et
leurs équipes génè 1 Millard 700
millions de recettes télévision pourquoi
parce que à l'extérieur à l'étranger la
vente des images procure un milliard d'
là où nous nous sommes à 30000 million
d'euros en France mais pourquoi il y a
30 millions d'euros parce que on a des
équipes qui jouent d'une part dans des
infrastructures qui sont des
infrastructure dépassé quelquefois
dangereuse et que l'opportunité de
l'Euro 2016 va permettre de réussir
totalement ce challenge sportif
économique et social et c'est le dernier
point que je voulais rappeler dans une
période de conjoncture extrêmement
difficile créer comme nous le faisons
plus de 2500 emplois pendant la période
de 30 mois de construction qui sont de
vrais emplois qui n'existeraiit pas si
la construction ne faisait pas le
préfet disait que déjà les courbes sur
la région sont en train d'évoluer à la
hausse pour un élu du conseil régional
ça devrait être quelque chose de
formidable de considérer surtout
égard aux accords qui ont été faits avec
le pli uniest local qu' a une priorité
des demandeurs d'emploi locaux dans
cette création et sur le fonctionnement
du stade sur sur l'exploitation c'est
1500 emplois permanents plus 2000 les
soirs de matchs ou les soirs
d'événements donc voilà donc je crois
qu'il y a pas de question à se poser si
on peut diminuer l'investissement des
collectivités territoriales et je rentre
pas dans un débat qui demanderait plus
de temps faut-il le faire quand on a la
possibilité de le faire par un
investissement privé ou par des PPP qui
à ma connaissance ranchérissent quand
même fortement le coût de la
collectivité territoriale parce que à
l'arrivée du PPP et évidemment que c'est
la collectivité qui assumeah il faut
dieu merci à Lyon il y a eu un certain
nombre d'investisseurs qui sont joués
lancés sur un projet créateur
d'emploi modèle vertueux sur le plan
économique et en liaison avec le finanal
fairplay et qui vont permettre grâce à
une synergie entre l'investissement
public et l'investissement privé et bien
à la deuxème agglomération de France
d'avoir des équipements comme toutes les
autres agglomérations européennes voilà
ce que je souhaitaz dire peut-être un
tout petit peu long mais ça me
paraissait tellement important de pas
dire des choses qui n'existent pas et
surtout laisser une chance une
opportunité fantastique à la France de
réussir sa mutation sur le plan des
équipements sportif parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que on est un pays un peu
sous-développé en matière d'équipement
sportif
merci merci beaucoup donc je donne la
parole tout de suite à à notre
rapporteur Stéphane Mazard qui posera
qui va vous poser les premières
questions oui merci monsieur le
Président donc si une question je vais
peut-être
reprendre l'ordre des
interventions alors une première
question à Monsieur gaayant donc on a
bien compris vous dites plus il y a
d'alléas sportif plus il y a une
légitimité pour les collectivités
locales donc d'investir moins il y a
d'alléas sportifs à ce moment-là mieux
vaut laisser la place au privés et vous
euh en votre qualité d'économiste du
sport vous vous proposez donc de fixer
un seuil de 50 % de financement public
lorsque 15 % au moins des équipes sont
relégués dans un championnat chaque
année euh lorsque vous parlez de 50 %
donc de financement public est-ce que
vous parler de l'investissement sur
l'infrastructure sportive au sens strict
où est-ce qu'il faut entendre donc
l'investissement dans une acceptation
plus large euh notamment euh les
transports la war en fait tout ce qui va
autour effectivement de l'infrastructure
sportive gant alors merci donc bon j'ai
donné ce ce chiffre de 50 % un peu à
titre indicatif parce que comme je vous
ai dit il est très difficile de fonder
économiquement aujourd'hui ce que serait
un seuil il faudrait avoir une
estimation de du Welfare engendré par le
spectacle sportif de de de ces équipes
professionnelles bon je pense
qu'effectivement c'est c'est c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait englober
aussi en partie les infr structure
annexe hein donc bon je enfin très
concrètement effectivement j'ai envie de
dire monsieur olas joue sur du velours
parce que je suis en effet plutôt
partisan du modèle tel qu' tel qu'il est
développé à Lyon il est vertueux en ce
sens que le stade est sur financement
privé et finalement la les collectivités
vont financer l'accompagnement avec les
infrastructure donc voilà on entre dans
quelque chose qui me paraît relativement
sain même si je n'ignore pas qu'il
puisse y avoir des des des éléments
peut-être sujet à controverse en tout
cas dans le bassin local mais je je
pense qu'effectivement il est rationnel
d'aller vers un modèle comme celui-là et
on est certainement dans le plafond du
financement public dans le cadre de ce
qui se passe à Lyon donc oui alors le
point évidemment qui qui qui qui émerge
c'est
doit-on fixer un taux de relégation plus
faible parce que l'on on va plus vers le
le modèle
nord-américain ça c'est c'est un peu le
débat et là là je pense que bon un grand
nombre des gros acteurs du football
français sont rép partisans d'une
limitation des relégations ou peut-être
même de de l'attribution de Wild Card
quand des grosses structures avec des
gros investissements sont menacés par la
relégation sportive bon voilà il y a
quelque chose qui est à à établir il y a
un curseur à positionner je crois que
c'est la responsabilité de la Ligue mais
dans un débat avec l'ensemble des
collectivités des clubs bien sûr qui
sont les constitutifs de la Ligue euh
pour savoir quel modèle on veut et je
crois une fois encore que plus l' plus
on va vers ce modèle de financement
privés des stades bien plus euh il peut
être opportun de réduire les relégations
euh mais voilà plus on va vers un
financement public tout compris hein
peut-être et bien plus il faut euh
contraindre parce que c'est c'est un
bien public dans ce cas-là c'est
beaucoup plus un bien public qu'un bien
privé ou en tout cas c'est quelque chose
de mixte il faut aller vers vers cette
relégation relativement substantielle
hein parce que on est plus dans le champ
de de l'équité ou de de voilà de cette
espèce de de promotion au mérite sportif
qui qui assure à tous les territoires
l'opportunité de d'accéder au spectacle
sportif de la plus grande qualité merci
monsur le rapporteur peut-être pour
rester sur cette
ce débat sur l'alléa
sportif est-ce que l'Olympique Lyonnais
a appréhendé cet alléa sportif dans le
montage donc financier de du de son
stade et puis peut-être la même question
à Vincy lorsqu'un opérateur se lance
dans une opération est-ce que cet alléas
sportif est appréhendé et comment
oui évidemment et et si nous ne l'avions
pas fait en tant qu'investisseur
évidemment les banquiers la Caisse des
dépôts qui est un investisseur comme les
autres c'est la première fois que
j'entends dire que la Caisse des Dépôts
serait assimilable en terme de
subvention à une subvention
publique c'est un investisseur dieu
merci qui intervient dans beaucoup
d'entreprises heureusement et donc tous
ces gens qui investissent euh nous ont
imposé comme nous l'aurions fait
nous-même en tant qu'investisseur privé
sur un certain nombre
d'hypothèses qui tiennent compte bien
sûr d'un certain nombre de performances
mais aussi de l'utilisation de
l'infrastructure pas uniquement par
rapport au club résident parce que on
l'a dit tout à l'heure les estimations
de recettes complémentaires ne viennent
pas de enfin dans notre projet de droit
à construire c'est c'est complètement
faux bon je trouve même absurde qu'on
puisse imaginer que ça soit le cas donc
je je le dém au passage ça a été dit non
ce sont des recettes qui sont liées au
fait qu'on est dans une zone qui a une
infrastructure qui est rentabilisée avec
deux destinations une destination B2B
c'està-dire business to business pour
les entreprises avec un centre comme l'a
évoqué Alain en matière d'utilisation de
séminaires d'action on a développé aussi
un concept qui est nouveau sur le plan
économique qui trans forme vous savez
ces loges qui d'habitude sont utilisé
par un certain nombre d'entreprises les
soirs de match ou d'événement en une
utilisation permanente c'està-dire que
le bureau est prolongé d'une loge et
l'entreprise
acquierre le bureau et la loge pour le
moment du match mais c'est un lieu de
vie permanent aussi en en Business to
Business c'estàdire que l'entreprise est
là pour utiliser l'auditorium qui est à
l'intérieur les structures de services
qui sont
autour même chose par par rapport au B2C
par rapport au consommateurs il y a
toute une
série de choses qui permettent au
consommateurs aux spectateurs aux
supporters bien de pouvoir utiliser les
infrastructures pour le match mais aussi
pour tout ce qu'il y a autour puisque il
y a un musée du sport à l'intérieur il y
a un certain nombre d'activités
périphérique qui permettent aux enfants
éventuellement d'être gardés pendant que
les parents vont au match par parce que
bon et donc toutes ces recettes qu'elles
soient orienté entreprise ou qu'elles
soi orienté consommateur on fait l'objet
de
simulation très complexe et très
technique il y a des organismes de
marketing d'évaluation pour tenir compte
de la qualité des prévisions qui ont été
faites et qui permettent c'est même une
une loi statistique qui fait des qui
s'appelle la loi de o qui permet de
faire des tirages sur toutes les
hypothèses et sportives et de recettes
pour vérifier que le business plan qui a
été conçu bon et croyez-vous que si le
business plan ne tenait pas la route
l'investisseur privé se substituerait à
l'investisseur public pour se lancer
dans une telle opération non il y a une
synergie qui tient compte et bien d'un
nouveau mode de vie de recettes qui sont
vérifié on parlait tout à l'heure de
Nice bon le St de Nice est plein
régulièrement il vient de
d'arriver et je pense pas d'ailleurs que
son classement puisse justifier à
lui-même le stade de Lille la moyenne de
Lille je crois depuis 1 an est passé de
13000 spectateurs de moyenne dans le
stade ancien à près de 34ou 40000 40000
mais pourquoi ben parce que uniquement
les gens viennent dans le stade bien sûr
supporter leur équipe mais aussi parce
que c'est un événement c'est un
spectacle il a été cité par Damien tout
à l'heure les multiplexes c'est
exactement la même chose vous aviez dans
le temps une salle de cinéma avec 100
150 places où il n'y avait que l'écran
de cinéma et rien autour aujourd'hui
dans toutes les villes là où il y avait
une salle il y a des dizaines de
multiplexes qui multiplient par 20 ou
par 30 le potentiel et bien ils sont
pleins non pas parce qu'il y a plus
d'amateurs de cinéma en tant que tel ou
que les films sont meilleurs mais parce
que c'est un mode de vie et ne pas tenir
compte de cette évolution de la
sociologie c'est faire une erreur tout à
fait conséquente en matière
d'estimation d'intérêt du public et donc
de recette
pour peut-être monsieur rajou aussi qui
a été ai interpellé par le rapporteur
oui bah écoutez ce qui est très à
prendre en compte quand même c'est la
différence entre la Ligue 2 et la Ligue
1 c'est
de manière économique je pense que le
format Ligue 2 est un format très
complexe
objectivement on parle de 35 % de
remplissage en Ligue 2 sur l'ensemble
des
stades donc ce qui est pas du tout le
cas de la Ligue 1 donc le passage ce qui
est très compliqué c'est d' pour un club
c'est de passer de Ligue 1 en Ligue 2
parce que ces charges ne peuvent pas les
recettes diminu les charges restent et
quoi c'est compliqué de baisser de
manière proportionnelle les charges au
même niveau et et ça a aspiré c'est
assez complexe ce qui est arrivé au club
notamment du
man parce que à mes yeux il y a deux
divisions qui sont vraiment différentes
donc oui on essaie de d'avoir une
réflexion sur l'alléa sportif mais ces
stades là tels qu'ils sont faits génèent
principalement des revenu sur du sur de
la Ligue
1pp peut-être justement restons sur
l'exemple du M d'après vous qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui s'est pas bien passé
au
m qu'est-ce qui a pas été anticipé ou
mal anticipé je quo qu'est-ce qu' a mal
été anticipé je sais pas je je pense que
le club a été un club qui a grandi très
vite hein puisque céit un club qui était
principalement en Ligue 2 qui est arrivé
en Ligue 1 qui a eu des vrais résultats
en Ligue 1 qui a formé des grands
joueurs qui a vendu des grands joueurs
je crois que il a il a grandi très vite
euh et puis sa chute a été extrêmement
rapide de l'autre côté à l'image de sa
montée on va dire ça c'est c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué parce que
l'infrastructure elle est physique elle
est là et elle elle est sur du ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur le temps long
ce qu'il a fallu peut-être c'est une
vraie réflexion que moi j'ai porter
c'est quand un club a une difficulté
comme ça et qu'il est investi dans des
infrastructures qui sont lourds que ce
soit un centre d'entraînement ou un
stade est-ce qu'il y a pas moyen d'avoir
une caisse au niveau des
clubs pour l'aider à passer ce cap là
d'avoir une caisse financière une aide
financière un soutien financier parce
que le passage Ligue 1 Ligue 2 est très
compliqué objectivement est très
compliqué ça peut exister dans le monde
de la musique hein si vous voulez dans
le producteurs il y a au sein du
Syndicat des producteurs français il y a
une aide pour un producteur qui a une
difficulté
donc une réflexion à se poser là j'ai
pas la réponse mais force de constater
qu'il a pas passé le cap du passage
Ligue 1 Ligue 2 il a pas pu supporter
de réduire ses charges du jour au
lendemain c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement difficile alors que le stade
était
là peut-être président las pour
compléter c'est c'est un complément mais
qui correspond en terme technique à la
problématique qui a été évoqué par
Damien c'est-à-dire que la ligue
professionnelle en liaison avec le
syndicat professionnel qui est
d'ailleurs présidé par le président du
Havre a mis en place ce qu'on appelle
une licence club un peu ce qui est fait
d'ailleurs sur le plan européen qui va
faire en sorte qu'il y a une adéquation
entre le niveau minimum requis
d'équipement et la captation d'un
certain nombre de ressources de manière
à faire en sorte que ben si il y a une
évolution qui est souhaitée des
équipements et bien il puisse y avoir
une forme de régulation économique celui
qui ne fait pas les investissements dans
les stades ne perçoit pas économiquement
évidemment les ressources en particulier
de droit télé qui viennent abonder au
contraire ceux qui font les
investissements donc c'est une
régulation interne qui doit d'ailleurs à
mon sens rester dans le cadre de la
gestion du du football professionnel et
qui peut permettre peut-être
d'arbitrer ce yatus qui a été évoqué
c'est de savoir si la collectivité peut
aller au-delà d'un certain niveau de
d'investissement ou d'équipement et par
la même euh avoir en terme de de retour
et un peu ce qui s'est mal passé au m
les ressources nécessaires pour que et
cetera puis deuxièmement effectivement
il y a le sujet des rétrogradations il y
a aussi le sujet du nombre euh de clubs
qui doivent participer en première
division bon il y a des modèles à 20 le
modèle allemand est à euh 18 euh modèle
italien euh a évolué aussi et donc il
peut y avoir des des régulations des
péréquations en terme de revenus qui
peuvent permettre de de venir compenser
ce ce très gros handicap et cetera mais
après c'est un problème aussi de de de
de taille par rapport à à
l'agglomération Le Havre démontre très
bien que on peut je pense qu'il faut pas
faire le même stade à Lyon qu' Avre
évidemment donc il faut être raisonnable
et pour être raisonnable ben il faut
aussi probablement mettre un peu
d'investissement privé je veux pas dire
que les collectivités itoriales sont pas
raisonnables mais je veux dire
l'engagement privé permet d'amener une
forme de régulation dans le projet et
qui probablement est à la source c'est
pour ça que je moi je je pense
qu'effectivement le le modèle avec le
plus d'investissement privés mais pas
uniquement parce que tout peut pas
passer par l'investissement privé mais
là où c'est possible ben il faut le
priviléger
voilà merci quelques questions de nos
collègues monsieur Billi Dominique
oui enfin d'abord remercier les
différents intervenants et peut-être sur
quelques
points un commentaire et et peut-être
quelques questions alors d'abord j'ai
entendu est-ce que on se pose la
question est-ce qu'il faut construire ou
pas des stades des
salles pour faire rapide je pense que si
le potentiel sportif est présent si le
potentiel populaire est présent si si il
y a un développement économique déjà
présent sur le territoire je pense que
l'élu local va se dire ben on y va on
construit il y a une dynamique qui est
là il faut essayer de
l'accompagner la la question la deuxième
question c'est qui qui construit qui
prend la maîtrise d'ouvrage alors on l'
on l'a
vu lors des des interventions il y a
plusieurs hypothèses effectivement je
crois qu'il faut essayer de s'adapter en
fonction des territoires
soit si je prends la dernière
intervention du président AAS on y va
c'est que du privé pour l'élu local
banco on y
va je suis un peu plus pessimiste que
vous président aujourd'hui en
France vous allez le
réussir je je pense je ne pense pas
qu'aujourd'hui d'autres projets
franco-français peuvent émerger mais
peut-être que dans quelques années il y
aura cette possibilité mais aujourd'hui
je pense que vous êtes quand même unique
2uxè deuxème hypothèse c'est la maîtrise
d'ouvrage direct de la collectivité
locale bah oui mais il faut qu'en amont
le club professionnel qui va bénéficier
de l'infrastructure soit complètement
associé à la gestion et là je rejoins
monsieur parce que c'est le point
essentiel du développement économique on
construit bon il y a l'alléa sportif là
aussi je l'évacue rapidement mais pour
que ce soit péren il faut quand même
sortir un peu de business quoi de profit
et si le club n'est pas gestionnaire ça
peut être compliqué donc c'est vrai que
l'exemple du Havre je me suis permis
avec mon collègue t Chini de citer en
exemple dans notre rapport d'information
il me semble pertinent parce que c'est
la collectivité locale bien sûr qui
investit mais qui va bénéficier d'un
loyer en retour et ce loyer en retour il
faut qu'il soit pérenne qu'il soit
important et donc donc il faut que la
société privée elle dégage des bénéfices
et donc bien en amont elle a été
associée pour que l'outil
soit corresponde à son hypothèse de
développement économique après il y a le
PPP parce que effectivement le PPP c'est
aussi une hypothèse c'est un outil vous
avez pu remarquer que dans notre rapport
d'information on on attire quand même
une attention particulière sur ce
montage parce qu'il faut qu'il soit bien
évidemment est bien travaillé là aussi
en amont ça peut être le cas à Lille on
voit que c'est un dossier intéressant ça
peut être une catastrophe pardonnez-moi
cette expression au man parce que je
crois que dans certaines situations il
n'a pas été cadré correctement on a
peut-être vu trop grand à l'instant où
on a signé le contrat par que quand on
fait un contrat de PPP on a tout intérêt
pour qu'il soit signé par les deux
parties à faire valoir que ça va être
beau quoi ça va être bien qu'on va
gagner de l'ARG argent mais il y a quand
même quelques risques il y a quand même
quelques risques et aujourd'hui on voit
la difficulté dont se trouve la
collectivité locale au man voilà moi je
je pense que il y a pas un modèle
unique et qu'il faut en fonction des
territoires en fonction des volontés
politique et économique local pouvoir
monter son projet de territoire et c'est
vrai que au bout du bout j'en termine
Président
j'ai Mo j'ai pas vous savez des
questions j'ai j'ai eu l'occasion je
suis un peu passionné par ce sujet donc
j'ai modestement donner peut-être aussi
des éléments de réflexion je pense que
l'idéal oui ce serait du privé avec un
accompagnement public parce qu'il est
indispensable pour que en approche
effectivement l'aménagement du
territoire corresponde à un projet
global et pas uniquement sur et pour le
stade de Lyon parce que oui il faut il
faut des transports mais ces transports
il faut qu'il fonctionne toute l'année
sinon les collectivités locales ne sont
pas dans leur rôle et dans leur mandat
d'investir mais je crois quand même que
aujourd'hui c'est unique ce que vous
allez et vous êtes en train de monter je
suis désolé Président j'ai pas de
question on va laisser la parole à notre
collègue monsieur Jean-Marie 22 Renberg
leberg je vois que c'est toujours assez
compliqué pour les noms consonance
flamande mais je suis sénateur du pas
decaléis hein rassurez-vous je suis pas
flamand euh d'origine seulement bon
euh à ce titre je suis supporteur de
lance et je viens un peu en
contradiction comme toi d'ailleurs en
contradiction avec ce que vous disez la
Ligue 2 ça peut marcher aussi àance il y
a 30000 spectateurs en moyenne mais
c'est un modèle un peu particulier je
l'avoue je le connais depuis 50 ans bon
alors je voulais moi moi poser
premièrement me féliciter de la qualité
de de cet échange qui je crois était
nécessaire au regard évidemment des
objectifs de notre
mission bien sûr on parle du foot parce
que c'est le sport roi mais évidemment
que les stades peuvent concerner
d'autres sports vous l'avez dit vous
vous l'avez rappelé il n' demeure pas
moins que il y a une focalisation il y a
un focus terrible sur le sport
foot qui est le sport ro pas seulement
en France mais en Europe alors je
voulais poser quelques questions je vais
pas faire de développement quelques
questions à Monsieur olas monsieur
Rageot monsieur caldar là je crois qu'
qui sont les plus réceptifs à ce que je
vais dire parce que je suis à peu près
convaincu qu'il faut
effectivement changer de
modèle que je l'espère l'Euro 2016 le
permettra
mais je me pose une question et je pose
une question peut-être à Monsieur has
combien de temps faudra-t-il pour que ce
modèle marche en
France quelles sont les conditions on a
on a évoqué la question du modèle unique
ou pas moi je pense que il y a une
période transitoire à envisager et que
néanmoins faut avoir un objectif clair
si on veut réussir on ne doit pas
pouvoir aller comme ça dans l'inconnu il
faut savoir ce qu'on veut et
veut-on moi j'appellerai pas ça food
business mais il faut bien avouer que
nous sommes dans une démarche business
et vous l'avez excellemment
démontré je crois que beaucoup d'autres
l'ont emprunté avant nous je je suis
j'étais maire d'une ville qui s'appelle
arace qui était jumelée avec erten erten
c'est gzal Kiren c'està-dire chalk
chalkfir le stade de chat c'est un STAC
de l'Alliance aussi c'était en tous les
cas je sais pas si il sont encore
les partenaire mais c'était pour moi un
modèle avant la lettre avant qu'il il
n'en ait d'autres en France comme lî ou
comme je dirais d'autres lesp ou comme
Nice ça a servi de modèle et pourtant on
est dans une zone vraiment comparable à
celle de l'an c'est-à-dire vraiment une
zone minière en dépression bien entendu
beaucoup de chômage et ça
fonctionne le modèle économique
fonctionne il y a du monde de stade mais
ce stade est vraiment agréable il
fonctionne sur un modèle B2B bien sûr et
cetera donc je me pose vraiment cette
question tout en espérant avoir une
réponse pouvoir apporter des réponses
positives ensuite vous avez évoqué les
aléas sportifs c'est vrai quand l'Ance
est descendu c'était le drame puisque il
a
fallu le Crédit Agricole une banque pour
porter je dirais heureusement la
transition parce que Gervet Martel a
réussi à trouver un investisseur qui est
en quelque sorte le Sauveur je
l'espère je l'espère mais en tous les
cas le projet sportif fonctionne donc je
dis est-ce qu'il faut toujours espérer
pour un club qui descend je pense au m
je connais bien aussi son maire est-ce
qu'il faut espérer des des solutions de
cet ordre pour pouvoir remonter j'ai
bien aimé ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure quand vous évoqueiez la WI card
comme aux États-Unis ou comme ça existe
dans le tennis faudrait inventer sans
doute des systèmes qui
permettraient d'assouplir en quelque
sorte la brutalité d'une descente
évidemment et ses conséquences
économiques si on veut faire marcher le
modèle mais après tout l'Allemagne
fonctionne l'Angleterre ça fonctionne et
pourtant les descentes sont brutales
aussi donc ce sont des questions bien
sûr et dernière question c'est le droit
d'image vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
je crois monsieur
has que en Angleterre le droit d'image
généré par les clubs était d'un milliard
d' je me suis pas trompé je pense et
vous dit 30 millions en France donc on
n'est pas sur les droits télé
là droit télé internationau ah d'accord
droit télé internationau j'avais pas
c'était la question que je vis posé
j'avais pas trop compris la différence
avec les droits des diffuseurs français
voilà et bien merci donc merci chers
collègues donc peut-être des réponses à
à plusieurs voix monsieur olas monsieur
calderala et Monsieur rajou peut-être
pour répondre aux questions de notre
collègue il y a un point qui
quel est le modèle français parce que je
je pense que certes il y a un modèle en
Angleterre qui fonctionne il y a un
modèle en Allemagne qui fonctionne mais
il faut nous laisser du temps quand même
pour le créer quoi je parle toujours du
temps long on a une force aujourd'hui on
a une force en France une particularité
euh c'est d'avoir deux championnats de
haut niveau un championnat de de
football de haut niveau et un
championnat de rugby de haut niveau ce
qui est pas le cas des autres pays déjà
moi je pense que le modèle français déjà
pour grandir puisque un club de
foot vous allez voir que quand on va
construire ces nouveaux stade on a
besoin dans le modèle économique d'avoir
d'autres
événements si on regarde bien on voit
bien que le rugby qui est très développé
peut permettre à un stade créé par un
club de foot ou à l'initiative d'un club
de foot de se développer créer ce cercle
vertueux mais une fois que je dis ça
c'est pas si simple ça veut dire qu'il
faut travailler les calendriers ça veut
dire qu'il faut travailler sur des
pelouses comp
pour recevoir à la fois du foot et du
rugby ça veut dire qu'il faut laisser
une place à un stade qui est coloré
quelque part un peu à l'image du club de
foot qui puisse devenir le jour où on
accueille le rugby à l'image du club de
rugby si vous voulez on a une chance en
France d'avoir ces deux championnats
donc nos stades peuvent deveniroi d'une
manière générale des stades régionaux
qui permettent bien sûr il y a un club
qui est leader naturellement mais il
doit pouvoir accueillir d'autres clubs
de ce qui a été fait à Nice avec le sur
l'alliance Riviera avec le Racing Club
de toulomb le Rugby Club de toulomb
pardon je pense
que on peut créer le marché grâce à ça
grâce à cette spécificité là mais ça
veut dire vraiment en amont que les deux
ligues se parlent que les deux
fédérations se parlent pour créer cette
valeur là et je pense que ce soit un
club un stade en PPP ou un stade privé
ou un stade d'une collectivité c'est le
même sujet on a besoin le foot
aujourd'hui euh mis à part le le le PSG
mais qui est complètement à part où il
feront il y aura que du foot au Parc des
Princes sur les autres stades on a
besoin d'autres événements voilà c'est
le modèle économique qui veut ça ce qui
est pas le cas si vous voulez de
l'Allemagne ou de l'Angleterre dans
certains cas mais parce qu'on partait
d'un historique quand même où il déjà
certains clubs étaient déjà possédé déjà
d'un actif donc en revendant l'ancien
stade ils ont pu réinvestir dans le
nouveau stade ou de base client
extrêmement développé de base diateur là
on part avec un peu de retard à
l'allumage donc je dis je dis que j'ai
bien aimé la la notion de période trans
transitoire je pense que voilà il faut
du temps et y compris au m et je
terminerai par là je pense que euh
fameux
partenaire privé pour l'instant il est
encore là alors qu'il y a plus de club
je crois que c'est à prendre en
considération vis-à-vis d'une
collectivité on essaie de trouver des
solutions avec une collectivité c'est
prévu contractuellement mais il faut
quoi on est là pour essayer de trouver
cette solution là c'est pas si simple il
y a plus de club
résident monsieur calderal donc moi je
vais rejoindre un petit peu les propos
de Damien puisque c'est vrai que quelque
part pour vivre un stade ça peut pas
vivre que sur 19 dates donc il faut
vraiment vivre sur une multitude
d'événements à l'inverse il y a pas que
les événements on va dire sportifs il y
a aussi les événements culturels et là
aussi après c'est je vais rejoindre un
petit peu ce que disait le sénateur il
il faut aussi quelque part après qu'il a
une réflexion locale donc un un modèle
économique unique c'est impossible pour
le moment sinon ça veut dire que pour
reprendre ce que disait monsieur gaayant
tout à l'heure demander à guingan
d'avoir un stade avec le le bassin
économique qu'ils ont donc ça serait un
peu compliqué je veux dire il faut après
reprendre voilà il faut reprendre le
territoire à la base il faut reprendre
le territoire je pense que chaque modèle
économique est différent en fonction de
son territoire et en fonction de ce
qu'il veut en faire à l'inverse après
s'il y a investissement ou non du de la
collectivité s'il y a un investissement
de la collectivité je pense que c'est un
un investissement où il faut réfléchir
pas sur du court terme ni du moyen terme
mais sur du long terme c'està-dire que
demain si vous construiser un stade dans
une
commune nous on a voulu qu'il soit de
25000 places qu'on a pas cherché à faire
35000 parce que sinon c'était pour de
dates ça aurait coûté cher les deux
dates parce que pourrait espérer avoir
des dates européennes mais à l'inverse
pas que dans le sport vous prenez une
ville qui n'a pas de palais des congrès
est-ce qu'il est pas judicieux peut-être
maintenant de penser à greffer dans un
stade un palais des congrès est-ce qu'il
est pas judicieux maintenant dans un
stade de faire un petit peu ce qu'a fait
Munich de greffer peut-être un genre de
petit centre commercial euh certains
certains certaines sociétés allemandes
qui gèent les stades vous venez les
loges comme le disait le président AAS
tout à l'heure eux ils vont mettre des
bureaux eux hors match ils en font des
chambres d'hôtel je dire après il faut
avoir une multitude de de possibilités
mais à l'inverse après si moi je
reprends un petit peu aussi l'exemple du
M parce que bah on a on s'est tous
rapprochés les uns des autres c'est pour
ça qu'on se connaît pratiquement tous
les stades et tout à l'heure j'ai oublié
de le dire mais contrairement à ce qu'on
pense les les ligues ils travaillent
dessus puisque moi je suis même membre
d'une commission qui a créé la Ligue
cette année qui est la commission
d'exploitation des stades donc c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui nous
intéresse à tous mais demain c'est que
si on nous crée beaucoup de comment
dirais-je de salalles dans une ville
c'est clair que on on te fait de
l'autoconcurrence entre nous surtout si
c'est des délégations de service public
qui sont donné puisque quelque part en
fait après le bassin économique reste
toujours le même quand vous faites des
séminaires ou un concert moi quand je
regarde leement et que je voyais la
salantaress à côté c'est c'est dur parce
que la salantaresse elleelle est
couverte tous les tout le temps nous si
on veut faire un événement on va dire
qui soit sympathique déjà vous êtes en
extérieur on n pas la chance d'avoir le
toit de lîle donc déjà on a une courte
durée donc il faut trouver euh un
rapprochement avec la salle de concert
ce que nous on a essayé de faire au Avre
pour ne pas être en concurrence avec eux
sur certaines périodes mais à l'inverse
trouver quand nous on va organiser notre
concert qu'on va annoncer lundi ben
qu'on soit pratiquement unique à faire
un concert dans la région l'objectif
c'est aussi après travailler en toute
intelligence pour que ça soit le
territoire qui en soit gagnant c'est
certain qu'après si je reprends un peu
ce que disait monsieur Étienne tê tout à
l'heure après c'est sûr qu'on a des
intérêts puisqu'on est des société mais
à l'inverse la société si elle
fonctionne elle fait fonctionner la
collectivité et elle fait fonctionner
la la notoriété de la ville parce que
moi je sais que je suis pas breton s'il
y avait pas eu guingan je crois que je
connaîtrait pas la ville de guingan donc
c'était juste pour en foot c'est si je
prends le foot mais dans tous les sports
c'est comme ça donc c'est vrai qu'il
faut pas se figer sur un modèle
économique faire un cas une exception
parce que c'est vrai que là je vais
reprendre pour mes amis Lanois mais les
lançois c'est vrai que moi depuis
toujours je dis que quand ils naissent
ils sont déjà avec une petite cuillère
du RC lance donc c'est vrai que ils ont
un avantage sur nous c'est que je pense
qu'ils feront toujours le plein mais il
y a pas que vous prenez le modèle de
vous vous allez voir le Racing Club de
Strasbourg qui à l'heure actuelle fait
des affiches en je crois qu'il sont en
CFA qui sont énormes quoi donc je veux
dire il faut pas il faut pas se dire que
c'est
que la qualité du spectacle c'est aussi
après l'environnement et la volonté de
tous être ensemble donc c'est pour ça
que nous l'objectif a été de multiplier
nos activités pour pouvoir faire de
notre ville de notre communauté et de
notre rég et ben une région connue grâce
à ce qui s'y fait et ce qui s'y
passe président l puis après pierre
Martin oui je pense que de manière
synthétique il y a tout d'abord le
modèle structurel on était dans un
modèle français qui était
extrêmement basé précédemment pour les
stades sur un investissement public bon
c'est ce sur quoi la
réflexion s'est instauré euh et ça
correspondait à une époque euh mais
c'est vrai aussi que l'économie des
collectivités territoriales euh de
l'État a changé aussi ne pas tenir
compte de l'évolution des possibilités
des collectivités territoriales dans la
réflexion c'est aussi euh bon il y a eu
une deuxième évolution avec les PPP qui
correspondent je dirais à un
accompagnement privé euh d'un
investissement public parce que le le la
base reste la même mais pendant toute la
période du PPP l'accompagnement privé
existe ce qui permet de de différer en
fait globalement et pour le contribuable
le coût ou le prix de revient exact de
l'investissement et puis il y a le
modèle du futur qui est le modèle privé
alors voilà moi je cherche pas à
généraliser je crois que tous les
modèles doivent exister en fonction de
deux paramètres le
potentiel sportif déjà parce parce que
bien sûr l'histoire de de lance
populaire et et
sportive est formidable bon je pas faire
la promotion deolympique mais
l'olympiqueonel le seul club en France à
jouer régulièrement la Coupe d'Europe
c'est-à-dire les aléas sportifs on
arrive ça fait 18 années de suite
consécutive
que la compétition est jouée donc il y a
le potentiel sportif et puis bien sûr il
y a le bassin démographique et quand
vous êtes à la convergence à la
rencontre du potentiel euh sportif et
puis euh euh de cette démographie et de
ce potentiel ben il y a des analyses de
marché qui permettre de savoir si vous
pouvez prendre ou pas le risque après
ben il y a la dimension comme dans
toutes nos entreprises euh vous pouvez
euh éventuellement euh viser de manière
lowcost euh un équipement euh et puis
vous pouvez aussi euh de manière un peu
plus ambitieuse euh viser pour la ville
pour le club et pour la p rénité le plus
sophistiqué le le stade de de Lyon a
effectivement
58000 places mais surtout il est
qualifié par l'UEFA comme le plus avancé
sur le plan technologie 2.0 en terme de
télécommunication mais aussi sur le plan
d'accessibilité aux personnes à handicap
sur tout a été mis pour faire en sorte
que ça soit le plus référent sur le plan
européen ce qui fait d'ailleurs que dès
maintenant la Fédération française l'a
retenu pour être candidat à l'euro 2020
c'est le seul Stade Français qui est
candidat par la Fédération Française et
qui a été retenu par la Fédération
Française pour l'Euro 2020 donc on parle
même plus de l'Euro 2016 mais l'euro
2020 sera donc après ben
l'investissement privé une fois qu'on a
fait la 3ème étape mais qui n'est pas
obligatoire j'en conviens elle permet de
faire des choses plus ou moins
sophistiquées ou plus ou moins
importante sans avoir à utiliser de
manière peut-être inéquitable
euh les fonds publics voilà donc donc
moi je crois que on est dans une dans
une liberté dans une avancée peut-être
qu'on est un peu en avance par rapport
au modèle français euh et et j'en
conviens mais c'est la deuxème
agglomération de France et puis vous
avez des investisseurs qui sont proposés
pour jouer le jeu avec une intégration
au total dernier point c'est que le
modèle privé apporte une caractéristique
dont on aura besoin
euh je pense comme
d'autres clubs démontre le besoin
impératif d'avoir des investisseurs et
onattrape
pas des mouches avec du vinaigre voilà
il faut que le modèle économique
devienne performant et pour qu'il
devienne performant il ne peut devenir
performant qu'au travers de
l'infrastructure qui permet de générer
de spectacle donc ça va attirer derrière
des investisseurs qui vont venir en
relais euh et bien de ce qui était euh
n'oubliez pas Messieurs que il y a
quelques années une grosse partie euh
des revenus étaiit sous forme de
subvention de collectivité sur le plan
du fonctionnement des clubs euh tout
ceci a quasiment disparu à Lyon il y a
pas de euh il y a pas de il y a pas de
subvention on fonctionne oui oui non il
y a uniquement pour le centre de
formation et c'est minime c'est moins de
0,5 % du chiffre d'affaires donc on est
dans un contexte donc ça aussi ça évolue
et l'investisseur privé
vient évidemment se substituer aussi aux
possibilité de l'instant des
collectivités
territoriales Pierre Martin oui merci
monsieur le Président beaucoup de choses
ont été dite je vais en rajouter
quelquesunes si je peux pour dire en
écoutant les uns les autres que d'abord
la science infuse personne ne la
possède il y a un fait qui est
absolument certain c'est que notre
société évolue cette société évolue
nous en sommes nous en avons conscience
c'est pas pour autant que les GS doivent
dire voilà le modèle que l'on doit
suivre ou voilà en quelque sorte le
système qui doit être adopté mais nous
avons le droit et je pense que c'est ce
qui est fait à l'heure actuelle on
regarde un peu ailleurs pour voir ce qui
s'y fait et puis aussi on a le droit de
faire de faire preuve d'imagination ce
qui existe aussi il y a un élément qui
est sûr c'est que Monsieur dit il faut
absolument qu'il y ait de nouveaux lieux
de nouveaux centres de vie pour que les
gens puissent puiss passer puisque le
sport est un fait de société aussi puis
la culture pour que les gens puissent
passer un moment de plaisir un moment de
bonheur c'est c'est tous les 15 jours ou
c'est tous les 8 jours mais il faut
penser parce que quand j'entends dire le
sport ceci cela mais lorsqu'on parlait
de l'Ance c'est le peuple de lance qui
va au stade et c'est le peuple de lance
qui va passer un bon moment ils arrivent
avec leur sandwich ils achètent des
frites mais c'est un moment merveilleux
pour eux et pour rien au monde il
voudrait se passer de ça tous les 15
jours alors le problème et c'est la
question que je la première question que
je poserai c'est ce qui s'est passé au
Man au man est-ce qu'on a bien géré le
problème comme il fallait gérer est-ce
qu'on n pas eu les yeux plus grands que
le ventre car c'est vrai il y a eu une
montée en puissance du Man et puis et
puis le beau stade qui arrive en même
temps que les bons joueurs s'en vont car
c'était certainement pour faire face à
la trésorerie que les joueurs sont
partis je ne ferai pas de citation sur
tous ceux qui sont partis mais à l'heure
actuelle ils sont en Angleterre ils sont
à Marseille ils sont partout il y en a
qui se retrouve dans deux grands clubs
si ces gens-là étaient restés au m le
problème ne se serait pas posé alors
monsieur le Président vous parlez aussi
du fairplay financier je suis absolument
d'accord la DNCG c'est quelque chose de
merveilleux pour la France mais ça n'est
pas européen et on on essaie d'y tendre
monsieur Platini veut absolument imposer
cela or vous savez comme moi que les
régimes fiscaux ne sont pas les mêmes en
Espagne ils ont une imposition
différente les clubs par rapport en
France en Angleterre aussi et puis il y
a tous des aléas annexes que je ne vais
pas ressortir aujourd'hui sinon ça
ferait une longue discussion le DIC on a
parlé du DIC on parle des 75 % et bien
écoutez lorsque je fais le bilan cette
année des transferts qui sont réalisés à
l'intérieur en France métropolitaine oh
les plus importants ça tourne autour de
10 millions les plus important en
Angleterre en Espagne ça tour autour de
ça alors bon simplement il faut essayer
d'y penser et se poser la question du
pourquoi alors certes il y a les
recettes télévisées vous l'avez dit mais
ce sont tous des éléments alors comment
faire pour essayer de d'harmoniser tout
ça car sans harmoniser cela nous ne
pourrons pas demain avoir des clubs en
Europe qui susciteront évidemment un
intérêt formidable qui nous feront
regarder la télé pour les matchs de
Coupe d'Europe nous regarderons plutôt
les Anglais si ce sont les Anglais les
Allemands si ce sont les Allemands
d'autant que vous l'avez aussi dit que
en Allemagne depuis la construction de
depuis la la Coupe du Monde oui c'était
la Coupe du Monde et bien les les stades
ont changé alors une question combien
représente actuellement la billetterie
en Allemagne par rapport à ce qu'elle
représenté on a cité des chiffres qui
sont 12 % 15 % je pense qu'en Allemagne
ça a largement augmenté compte tenu de
ces stades qui sont plein et puis
lorsqu'on regarde en France il faut le
dire aussi écoutez il y a deux clubs qui
bénéficie des largesses venant de
l'extérieur ces deux clubs font le plein
dans les stades et je dois dire que dans
beaucoup des stades comme à Lille où il
y a eu de gros efforts de fait et bien
ma foi où qu'ils aillent ils attirent
les la la comment dirais-je les
supporters et bien attirer les
supporters ça fait du monde ça démontre
que nous avons besoin aussi d'actualiser
un peu nos stades d'autant que c'est
pour répondre une question et poser à
nouveau une autre question on parle de
de la Coupe d'Europe enfin de l'Euro
2016 enfin l'Euro 2016 le football le
voulait mais il y a pas que le football
qui le voulait je pense que tout le
monde voulait l'Euro 2016 et que tout le
monde avait conscience pu que s'il y
avait l'Euro 2016 il fallait de nouveaux
stades les négociations ont été menées
et je suppose Messieurs les Présidents
et les représentant du privé aussi que
les discussions ont eu lieu entre tous
c'est-à-dire entre tous les partenaires
pour savoir les solutions qu'on allait
adopter dans chaque secteur étant
entendu que ces solutions n'étaient pas
les mêmes alors ce sont des éléments
fort important et puis je crois que
qu'on le veuille ou non notre société a
évolué puisque je doisajouter aussi
puisqueun un petit mot a été dit sur le
sujet parlant du rugby parlant d'autres
sport le foot est professionnel depuis
un certain temps le rugby le devient et
enfin est devenu mais ça s'intensifie
bien nous allons voir comment cela va se
développer c'est très intéressant le
handball est aussi le volet en partie
donc on a tout cela qui évolue ce qui
veut dire que derrière tout cela il il
faut offrir du un spectacle mais dans
ces arènes si je ve dire ce ne sera pas
forcément je le suppose c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous ouvrez les ventails
ce ne sera pas forcément des spectacles
sportifs ce sera des spectacles qui
attireront du monde car c'est ce que
l'on veut et il est bien évident que sur
les terrains de foot et je félicite
d'avoir pensé à mettre une toiture car
il est évident que si on fait jouer les
All Black quand ils viennent en France
sur leur terrain de lîle puis que le
dimanche d'après on fait jouer match de
foot là comme je ne sais plus qui disait
ça l'autre jour on jouera sur un champ
de patate hein alors attention à tout ça
mais je dois dire qu'il y a une énorme
réflexion à mener une énorme réflexion à
mener et cette énorme réflexion doit
réunir tout le monde parce que il va de
soi que c'est un moment de plaisir qu'on
offre à notre population les uns le
trouveront dans la culture les autres
dans le sport les troisiè ailleurs mais
on peut satisfaire tout le monde en même
temps mais ne traînons pas les pieds
pour qu'administ rativement on passe t
de temps pour qu'administrativement on
fasse des choses qui bloquent les
systèmes c'est un besoin de notre
population car un peu d'oxygène chaque
semaine c'est pas mauvais et j'espère
que c'est sur tous ces sujets que vous
avez réagi que vous avez que vous êtes
interrogé que vous avez réfléchi pour
essayer de sortir des solutions qui
seront peut-être des solutions
françaises et qu'ailleurs on dira ben ma
foi en France ils ne font peut-être pas
exactement comme nous mais c'est aussi
bien oui je voulais intervenir sur deux
points parce que il y a il y a on a
parlé de la raison pour laquelle le club
du Man a connu cette infortune donc je
suis assez convaincu aussi qu'il y a une
part de mauvaise fortune hein le club a
fait de mauvais choix sportifs euh il a
tenté de se maintenir alors après sa
première relégation sa sa relégation en
2e division il avait gardé le plus gros
budget de Ligue 2 avec l'espoir de
remonter immédiatement il a terminé 3e
exéco mais 4e à la différence de but il
n'a pas pu remonter effectivement c'est
la spirale la pire qui qui qui se passe
mais euh puisqu'il a été question de la
licence club je veux dire aussi qu'il y
a peut-être un caractère un peu pousse
au crime de cette licence club parce que
la logique de la construction du mm
Arena était d'être le stade qui
correspondrait à tous les critères euh
qui permettent à un stade d'être au
niveau de certification maximum et le
maire duum d'ailleurs dit mais j'ai fait
un stade de 25000 mais on me demandait
d'en faire 30000 la Ligue me disait il
faut en faire 30000 c'est ça la norme et
la licence club c'est que quelque chose
qui effectivement pousse un peu au crime
aussi puisque dans l'état actuell les
choses où les collectivités financent
largement les clubs parce que et bien
les collectivités sont dans cette
surenchère de de construction alors une
fois encore si c'est le secteur privé
strictement ça ne me gêne pas tant que
ça mais si c'est le financement public
là il y a il y a une inefficacité
sociale et qui est accentuée par ce
processus de certification qui est la
licence club je rappelle hein c'est pour
l'instant seulement une part variable
des droits qui n'est plus alloué à ceux
qui n'ont pas le score suffisant à la
licence club comme le Gazelec d'Ajaccio
et le club de nior c'est c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait même puisqu'il a été
indiqué par la LI que le processus
allait se
durcir faire aboutir à pourquoi pas ce
que un club qui serait sportivement
promu ne puisse pas accéder à la Ligue
supérieure parce qu'il n'obtiendrait pas
un score suffisant à la licence club
hein donc comme beaucoup l'ont noté
c'est aussi un système de fermeture de
la de la Ligue 1 par exemple
alors il y a un deuxième point sur
lequel je voudrais juste venir c'est
j'ai entendu et je suis tout à fait
d'accord qu'il est très bien qu' existe
une DNCG et qu'il est formidable
qu'existe le fairplay financier mais je
pense que la représentation nationale
doit s'émouvoir de ce que les deux
grands clubs dont on parle qui attirent
tant de spectateurs pour l'un et bien ne
satisfait pas ses obligations en matière
fiscale et sociale en France et pour
l'autre a réussi par une pirouette avec
la Qatar Tourism Authority à ne pas
dérogé aux règles du fairplay financier
hein je crois qu'il est très important
toujours de de le mentionner parce que
oui il y a deux clubs qui sont euh à
l'origine d'un surcroix de fréquentation
mais les règles du jeu me sement pas
être les mêmes pour tout le
monde à l'inverse si vous écoutez tout à
l'heure ce qu'a dit le président has à
juste titre en Allemagne c'est pas le
premier ni le deuxème qui remplit les
stades c'est tous les tous les clubs qui
remplissent les stades pourquoi parce
que comme disait Damien tout à l'heure
on s'est bien posé la question et on a
accentué tout autour du spectateur et
l'objectif des nouveaux stades c'est
c'est cela vous venez dans un stade
maintenant moi je cite le stade du HAV
puisque je suis au HAV mais j'ai vu Nice
c'est pareil vous avez plus de gris
quand vous êtes en tribune Sud si vous
voulez boire un coup avec votre collègue
qui est en tribune Ouest vous pouviez y
aller alors qu'avant c'est vrai que tout
était sectorisé maintenant l'objectif
c'est d'assurer un spectacle de qualité
un accueil et de la sécurité qui soit
soit le moins visible mais qui soit
présente donc après c'est certain que de
dire que tel modèle ou tel modèle ou tel
stade tel stade l'objectif c'est de se
dire qu'il faut qu'on fasse comme les
Allemands l'ont fait ou comme les
Anglais le font c'est pas de prendre ce
qui ce qui se fait parce que pour faire
du cocorico mais d'essayer d'adapter
leur leur façon de voir à à ce qu'on
fait et peut-être après amener les
touches de spectacle que font les
Américains puisque quelque part comme le
disait Damien quand on est en Ligue 2 et
nous c'est le cas en Ligue 2 hormis
quand vous avez lance ou quand vous avez
un club qui a on va dire quelques
joueurs de renom vous faites le plein
mais à côté de ça trouver on va dire un
revenu supplémentaire à ce aux match aux
événements en greffant par-dessus ben
des animations en greffant un concert en
greffant des des des activités annexes
qui nous permettent d'espérer
euh un gain en en public et nous on le
voit parce qu'on a fait un test pour
voir si c'était faisable on a fait un
tout petit groupe du moins qui qui est
qui est pas très connu qui était le
frère de maître Gims pour voir si
c'était jouable on a ouvert nos ventes
nettement en amont par rapport à
l'habitude on a vu qu'on a vendu pour
eux 400 places mais avec les 400 places
on payait déjà leur caché et on arrivait
à augmenter la capacité du stade donc
maintenant il faut se poser la question
et au fur à mesure travailler de
concerts pour pouvoir avancer et de se
greffer ben comme on est en train de
voir tous les stade à travailler
ensemble pour créer une programmation
assez intelligente et c'est ce qui est
en train de faire la Ligue à avec Ben la
commission exploitation et de de
d'essayer de ramener ce qu'attend le
public Monsieur L monsieur après
monsieur tête et puis après rapporteur
monsieur tê vous avez demander la parole
allez-y oui simplement pour faire
quelques observations c'est difficile de
faire des comparaisons toujours entre la
France et l'Allemagne et puis de de de
chercher un modèle on donne par exemple
la zone zone de population comme bon
critère de savoir si on a les capacités
ou non de faire un stade la zone urbaine
de Munich c'est trois fois la zone
urbaine de l'agglomération lyonnaise et
le rapport de stade n'est que de 20 20 à
25 % de plus le stade de Munich en ce
qui concerne toujours les montages on
est toujours dans un discours de dire on
est dans un vieux cycle et qu'il faut
passer un cycle nouveau les les les
frontières ne sont pas aussi nettes
toujours pour donner l'exemple de Munich
quand ça s'est fait il y a 12 pr an la
commune de munique a vendu un terrain
pour réaliser ce projet et le terrain il
faisait un peu moins de 8 hactares il a
été vendu 192 € du mètre carré pour
réaliser le projet de l'agglomération
lyonnaise c'est une quarantaine
d'hectares publics qui sont vendus à 40
€ du mètre carré pour effectivement
faire toute une opération tout autour de
financement du stade donc on voit bien
que on ne peut pas être tout à fait dans
les comparaisons et les raisons on a
toujours aussi la difficulté c'est de
faire la différence entre le vrai
discours la réalité et puis le discours
de communication politique par exemple
on a entendu dans le discours une époque
qu'on pouvait vendre monsieur Benzema
100 millions d'euros en fait on ne l'a
vendu que 35 million d'euros donc
effectivement les comparaisons
internationales sont extrêmement
difficiles pour savoir à quel niveau on
peut vendre en France ou à l'extérieur
des joueurs ça marche pas de façon aussi
aussi pertinente et pour donner un
exemple de l'importance des
collectivités euh le tramou comme
d'autres opérations je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail mais par rapport à ce qui
a été dit qui est tout à fait erroné il
ne marchera que 28 jours par an c'est
dans le dossier d'enquête publique il ne
marchera pas 365 jours par an donc sont
des projets dédiés à hauteur un peu près
de 200 millions d'euros qui sont mis en
place par les collectivités on peut pas
dire que ça fait du développement
économique tout autour donc on voit bien
la difficulté dernier nière peut-être
observation c'est la capacité que l'on a
à mettre d'autres spectacles dans les
stades c'est une ambition tout à fait
louable mais on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
deux contraintes il faudra peut-être
trouver des solutions mais deux
contraintes la première contrainte c'est
la contrainte de calendrier plus vous
avez un grand stade plus les tourneurs
internationaux et pour mettre entretenu
à celui qui a fait venu fait venir
pardon Johnny HID au stade de Gerland
plus vous voulez remplir des stades
aussi importants même que gerl 40000
places avec il y en a pas tellement qui
peuvent les remplir plus les les les
tournées national ou internationale se
prépare longtemps à l'avance et comme
elle se prépare longtemps à l'avance on
a du mal à caler des dates hein et et
quand Johnny alidday est venu à Gerland
on a été obligé au dernier moment de
déplacer Johnny hidday et la ville de
Lyon a indemnisé le tourneur de Johnny
hidday pour le déplacement au dernier
moment de Johnny hidday donc donc c'est
assez compliqué et plus votre stade est
grand moins il peut être
multiactivité je vais donner deux un
exemple aussi sur la gestion le le choix
de la ville de Lyon a été de gérer en
direct les autres spectacles sur gerl on
peut en faire le choix de la ville de
Marseille a été l'inverse ils ont un
contrat avec le club sportif l'OM qui
est de dire vous faites ce que vous
voulez du stade essayez de le gérer et
de faire venir ce qui vous voulez en
plus du club de foot des stades qui ont
pas tout à fait la même stare il est
plus grand pour l'OM mais la réalité
c'est que ça soit la ville de Lyon ou
Marseille il y a peu d'événements
extérieurs qui ont été réalisés dans
Gerlan ou dans Marseille et c'est pas
tant un problème de d'infrastructure
périphérique sauf d'avoir un toit et je
vous ferai une réflexion sur les toits
possibles c'est la capacité d'avoir
vraiment des spectacles de ces niveaux
aussi importants des stades de plus de
40000 places et en ce qui concerne la
présence ou non d'un toit qui était
l'idée de départ de l'Olympique lunis
qui l'a abandonné peut-être à juste
titre c'est que là aussi pour remplir
une salle aussi grande avec un toit il
faut des tournées d'hivers des tournées
non pas de d'été et cetera et comme il y
a pas encore un réseau suffisamment
important en Europe de salle de ce
niveau-là et bien il y a peu de
créateurs de tourné divhivers donc on n
pas encore les moyens vraiment d'occuper
et de rentabiliser des toits sur les les
stades juste pour répondre avant avant
pour la tournée après je laisserai le
président Lass pour les tournées après
il faut il faut il faut arrêter de
penser aussi que tourné ça veut dire que
forcément c'est un gage de qualité après
vous être capable de vous de de gérer de
faire de la production nous on s essayé
l'année dernière pour voir un petit peu
ce qui était jouable on avait pas assez
d'expérience du moins on avait peu de
recul on avait peu de temps pour le
faire là à partir de lundi on va mettre
en vente earth Wind on fire cool on the
gang et imagin on sera les seuls en
France à le faire donc après et c'est
pas une tournée après vous êtes capable
de créer votre propre calendrier après
il faut juste prendre le temps de le
faire donc c'est pour ça dire que la la
la tournée c'est un gage de qualité pas
forcément parce que demain si vous
voulez prendre Bruno Mars vous pouvez
avoir Bruno Mars après c'est que un
problème de de finances et un problème
d'équilibre après c'est sûr que si vous
prenez un cachet exorbitant quand vous
avez un stade plus vous prenez un cachet
exorbitant plus quand vous allez diviser
par le nombre de places que vous allez
faire la place va être onéreuse après
c'est plutôt comme ça qu'il faut se
poser la question c'est de se dire où
est-ce qu''est le portefeuille local
quel est le prix maximal que je peux
donner à ma population pour pouvoir
avoir quelque chose de qualité donc nous
c'est plutôt à l'inverse qu'on s'est
posé la question c'est pour ça que les
tournées on en a eu des propositions
l'année dernière on aurait pu avoir
Johnny Hidé le on va dire que le le coût
global dépassé on va dire ce que nous on
entendait raisonnable pour le public
donc ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
décliné l'offre et donc là on fera on va
faire une autre propre création et on
est en train de regarder déjà pour en
faire une deuxième la veille donc
l'objectif c'est aussi de se poser la
question de ce qu'attend le local et de
ce qu'on est capable de faire après dire
une tournée c'est simple c'est sûr que
moi si je dois aller voir un concert en
tournée ben soit je vais au POB soit je
vais au Stade de France je suis à côté
je suis à 1h30 maintenant avec les
transports on est proche donc nous il
faut qu'on innve les stades de de
province on doit être innovant on doit
amener quelque chose qui est un peu une
création qui est la touche de notre de
notre région monsieur et puis après
monsieur le rapporteur oui donc c'était
une intervention
qui correspondait au sujet bon je
répondrai pas directement à Étienne tê
parce que bon tout ce qui dit est
infondé donc c'est pas la peine de d'y
revenir aujourd'hui les les tramou
fonctionnent et c'est vrai que par
contre les soirs de match ils ont des
configurations qui sont un peu un peu
différentes mais je ne reviendrai
pasdessus je reviens sur simplement deux
points qui concourent à l'analyse qui
peut permettre
demain de bien prior iser les différents
modèles qui sont en cours de de
réflexion premier point concernant le le
stade de Lyon
euh c'est un stade qui est modulaire
c'estàd que c'est pas un stade de 58000
PL c'est un stade de 20 ou de 40 ou de
60 nous avons très tôt dans la réflexion
bon si on nous avait pas empêché de
d'avancer aussi vite il serait
opérationnel donc c'est vrai que on a
perdu beaucoup de temps dans la
construction bon voilà au moins une
satisfaction euh je dirais euh perfide
mais qui qui existe très tôt on s'est
lancé dans la construction d'une équipe
féminine de niveau européen parce que
elle mobilise aussi en terme de club
résident et sans poser des problèmes qui
ont été évoqués sur le rugby tout à
l'heure euh évidemment aussi des
spectateurs et on peut très bien
fonctionner avec un 2uxème club résident
dans une couronne à 20000 ce qui fait
effectivement aussi euh des événements
euh la finale de la Coupe d'Europe que
nous avons gagné il y a 2 années à
Munich qui a au passage trois stades et
deux club de première division donc on
compare pas du tout les mêmes choses
voilà mais ceci étant quand on connaît
pas bien quelquefois on fait des erreurs
d'appréciation et donc nous avons joué
la finale devant une équipe allemande
devant 60000
personnes féminine bon donc ce qui
prouve qu'il y a un marché qui se crée
qui se développe et qui permet de la
deuxième point d'intervention que je
voulais faire euh est plus structurelle
sur l'analyse c'est-à-dire que en terme
d'évolution dans les choix on doit tenir
compte d'un certain nombre d'évolutions
qui sont les évolutions qui ont été je
sais pu évoqué tout à l'heure par le
rapporteur je crois euh dans les
analyses que fait la Cour des comptes
sur le prix de revient des stades
construits dans des modèles PPP ou des
modèles individuels et deuxièmement
puisque ça a été à la mode d'aller à
Bruxelles pour essayer de faire en sorte
de bloquer un certain nombre de choses
Bruxelles s'intéresse aussi
effectivement au prix de revien global
donc dans l'analyse future des choix il
va y avoir un paramètre supplémentaire
c'est est-ce que la relation entre le
club résident dans une solution de ce
typel et le maîre d'œuvre va être
uniquement guidé par les relations euh
conviviales et et politique locale ou
est-ce que des règles très précises
d'adéquation avec le véritable prix de
revien de
l'infrastructure sera mise en œuvre ou
pas et sont des règles qui peuvent être
Cours des comptes donc spécifiquement
françaises mais qui peuvent être aussi
européennes et donc voilà donc il faut
en tenir compte et c'est pour ça que
nous dans
notre analyse du choix et encore une
fois je veux pas
euh vendre uniquement ce modèle parce
que je crois qu'il y a les trois modèles
qui doivent persister en fonction de la
convergence sportive et de
démographie mais dans le choix qui nous
a amené à faire cette cette orientation
il y a d'une part le fait que comme on
va intégrer notre prix de reviens réel
dans le club puisque la foncière du
Montou est une filiale à 100 % du
club et
bien puisqu'on prend en compte euh tous
les prix de revient on prend en compte
aussi 100 % des ressources alors que
dans le modèle euh PPP vous ne prenez
pas 100 % si vous êtes le président des
ressources et par contre vous pouvez
être amené peut-être par des règles
malheureusement extérieure ou interne à
avoir une prise en compte de de 100 %
des ressources donc dans le choix du
gestionnaire de l'exploitant on a tenu
compte du fait que peut-être les règles
allaient évoluer euh bon
euh on voit déjà d'ailleurs des des
locations de stade qui qui évoluent la
la discussion entre les opérateurs et
les locataires est en train de d'évoluer
donc c'est un un paramètre qu'il faudra
aussi prendre en compte non pas du côté
de la collectivité territoriale mais du
côté de l'exploitant parce que il faut
qu'il ait la certitude que dans ces prix
de revient ben s'il a 100 % des charges
il faut qu'il ait aussi euh 100 % des
recette voilà c'est ce qui explique
aussi la différence tout à l'heure sur
la côe partart de billetterie
supplémentair ou de ressources
supplémentaires c'est que dans le modèle
qui est celui que nous avons choisi 100
% des ressources de billetterie mais
aussi de consommation qui sont autour
viennent effectivement dans le modèle du
club et de sa filiale
d'exploitation monsieur le rapporteur
oui Monsieur R excusez-moi pardonnez-moi
juste un complément parler du du modèle
PPP euh donc on va parler de l'Alliance
Riviera avec l'OGC Nice et la ville de
Nice ou du stade de Bordeaux 100 % des
revenus qui sont générés lors des matchs
organisés par l'OGC Nice vont à l'OGC
Nice
l'OGC Nice derrière paye un loyer en
direct à la à la ville à la collectivité
euh les charges de maintenance du
bâtiment les charge de ce qu'on appelle
renouvellement des équipements le fameux
gerer qui sont des choses le coût global
quand on parle de coût global c'est
c'est être capable de voir sur 30 ans en
fait ce que le stade va coûter et et
d'amortir quelque part des futurs
changements des écrans géants parce que
ça va devenir obsolè au bout de 6 7 8 9
années de certains équipements qui vont
devenir obsolèes C ces charges là
sont du côté de l'exploitant qui doit
derrière générer des revenus pour
pouvoir en payer une
partie c'est le modèle est est très
différent
mais
voilà monsieur le
rapporteur d'autres
questions vie privée donc propriété du
stade par le club une fois que le stade
est construit qu'il est édifié qu'il est
mise en fonctionnement qu'est-ce qu'on
attend de la collectivité
locale donc ça c'est une première
question pour vous peut-être je er les
questions monsieur gaayant on voit bien
que ce nouveau modèle économique qui
passe par une à minima une gestion de
l'infrastructure sportive par par le
club ben repose enfin c'est le modèle
allemand ou le modèle anglais repose
quand même sur la capacité à amener des
spectateurs en nombre en famille qui
consomment sur place est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui en France on peut on peut
faire le pari de d'un tel développement
est-ce que sociologiquement la France
est prête à ça c'est une autre question
je ne suis pas sociologue mais enfin
mais en tant qu'économiste je pense que
c'est ce que je pense c'est qu'il y a
quand même en France je vais terminer
peut-être les questions et voilà je
termine le tour comme ça tout le monde
après enchaînera et et Monsieur Rajot
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé vous de
cette difficile cohabitation entre le
spectateur et le diffuseur et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui ce rapport il est très
inégal et aujourd'hui c'est le diffuseur
qui impose ce qu'il veut aux
organisateurs de ce spectacle sportif
est-ce qu'il faut améliorer aujourd'hui
ces ces rapports et et comment peut-on
améliorer ces rapports parce que je
pense que les collectivités nous on est
intéressé à la vie d'un stade le fait
que nos citoyens nos habitants puissent
aller au stade qu'il soient pas qui
sonit pas mis en dehors du stade parce
que les prix sont prohibitifs ou parce
que les horaires sont pas du tout
compatibles avec la ville de tout un
chacun donc comment aujourd'hui on
rétablit cet
équilibre sur la première question ce
que nous attendons de la collectivité
dans le futur c'est un partenariat
permanent de
réflexion aujourd'hui autour du stade et
et pour répondre aux questions
d'infrastructure qui sont de transport
en commun
euh la collectivité envisage de mettre
un écoquartier à côté du stade pas du
tout sur les terrains du stade mais à
côté envisage de l'utre côté de faire un
centre commercial ce qui permet
effectivement d'avoir une synergie et de
d'apporter la réponse à la question que
vous avez posé c'est-à-dire comment
faire en sorte d'ouvrir au plus grand
nombre l'espace de lieu de vie qui vient
d'être créé et le deuxième point que
nous attendons de la collectivité locale
c'est de jouer le
jeu dans une une agglomération comme
comme
Lyon il y a ce nouveau stade qui
correspond effectivement à plein de
d'activités il y a un deuxième stade qui
est un stade de rugby qui est privé
aussi donc ce qui démontre que du loup
ce qui démontre aussi que bah il y a des
investisseurs qui sont pas uniques et
qui peuvent en fonction d'approche de
philosophie politique et bien s'y
intéresser et puis il y a le stade de
Gerlan dont les débuts de travaux ont
été fait en 1900 terminé en
1928 aujourd'hui bien que payant un
loyer extrêmement élevé
euh cette une gageur de de faire des
matchs de Coupe d'Europe avec un niveau
de de réception absolument incroyable on
est pour chassé par l'UEFA sur le plan
des infrastructures par parce que on n
plus du tout au niveau mais je pense que
il doit y avoir un un deal avec la
collectivité moi je pense que on n pas
besoin de concurrence d'un deuxème stade
donc il faut certainement imaginer une
destination différente et puis faire en
sorte que chacun et bien puisse dans une
collaboration faire en sorte que ceux
qui ont investi puissent ne pas avoir
une concurrence déloyale d'un autre
stade éventuellement à financement
public qui viendrait concurrencer les
ressources de ce stade privé voilà
Monsieur
Gayan sur la question de est-ce que ce
modèle peut peut fonctionner en France
alors moi je crois quand même qu'il y a
peut-être une addiction moins grande en
France au football puisqu'on parle du
football que ce qui existe en Angleterre
en Allemagne en Italie en Espagne et
même au Portugal donc il faut pas
négliger cet aspect là des choses je
crois que et c'est peut-être tant mieux
ça veut dire que les Français font un
arbitrage entre aller au cinéma au
théâtre et et au football et que ce
n'est pas nécessairement le réflexe
conditionné pavlovien d'aller au
football le samedi soir donc euh bon il
y a il y a il y a donc peut-être une
difficulté supplémentaire en France qui
peut expliquer aussi un retard ou une
plus mauvaise performance dans
l'ensemble de l'histoire des coupes
européennes puisque le la France
sousperforme en coupes européennes au
regard de sa richesse par tête au regard
de sa population donc ce point-là on
peut pas on peut pas le négliger après
effectivement il y a le le le le présent
et le futur sont sont de deux temps
différents et les les habitudes évoluent
et on peut dynamiser un modèle tout à
fait enfin les comportements changent
euh il y a quand même des des des des
indices qui sont pas toujours positifs
quand je pense à Orange qui avait
enchéri dans le précédent appel d'offre
pour les droits TV ceux qui étaient à
668 millions d'euros ils avaient donc ch
à hauteur de 200 million d'euros pour
une partie des lots et ils avaient
complètement surévalué euh la la
possibilité que des gens par leurs
abonnements orange et par leurs
smartphone et par le payperview et bien
allit demander le spectacle du football
et parce que on était sur une base
peut-être de ce qui se passe en
Angleterre où effectivement il y a il y
a une demande de cette nature elle est
plus faible en France et orange a dû
fermer boutique sur le football avant
même la fin euh de la période des droits
TV euh parce que et bien la demande
n'était pas à la même hauteur donc
effectivement la question me paraît
pertinente oui euh un modèle on va dire
de de ce type est sans doute possible en
France mais euh il n'y aura peut-être
pas le même le même succès la même
demande que ce qu'elle est en Allemagne
en Allemagne ça fait très longtemps que
la culture du football le samedi
après-midi euh est présente qu'on y va
en famille même si effectivement les
stades sur fond privés rénové construit
en 2006 ont
considérablement élargi en fait
l'audience du football allemand et le
nombre de spectateurs je pense que la
France part d'un point de départ qui est
un tout petit peu en
retrait euh oui sur concernant les
droits tél al je suis pas le mieux placé
parce que je suis pas mais ce que je
pense c'est c'est le focus qui va qui va
changer parce que les clubs qui
négocient au travers de la Ligue vont
avoir des intérê intérêt à défendre le
spectateur beaucoup plus important parce
que derrière le stade moderne a des
coûts plus important il est plus grand
il faut mettre plus de monde il y a un
loyer à payer qui est plus important que
l'ancien stade entre guillemets
municipal il y a plus de système
d'information activver donc il
représentera une charge pour le club
donc une nécessité pour le club de
générer des recettes et donc de défendre
le spectateur auparavant on aurait pu
dire que ça aurait pu se faire mais je
pense que
cette réflexion là elle devait pas être
naturelle parce que c'était masqué
peut-être par des coups de loyer
beaucoup plus bas du stade le cout du
stade était pas vraiment appréhendé de
la même manière là ça va devenir une
vraie réalité pour l'ensemble des clubs
qui vont jouer dans ces grandes
infrastructures quelle que soit la
formule certainement encore plus lourd
quand on est dans un format privé parce
que on est vraiment manette et je pense
que monsieur le président Jean-Michel
olas sera le premier à défendre les
spectateurs vis-àis des diffuseurs parce
que le cercle vertueux il est là il faut
remplir les stades et une fois qu'on
aura rempli les stades et que les stades
seront donc moderne on va pouvoir
réévaluer les droit les droits des
diffuseurs mais ça passe par d'abord
remplir les
stades c'est une conviction vas-y
oui peut-être on dit on voit bien que là
on est aujourd'hui à la recherche encore
une fois ce nou nouveau modèle
économique vous l'avez vous l'avez
également dit chacun à votre tour il
faut il faut également des lieux
sécurisés la question d'ailleurs se pose
de savoir si on va pas passer d'un
modèle avec des supporters qui viennent
avec les drapeaux on connaît ça on le
voit on le voit tous les weekends à un
modèle de tribune beaucoup plus
asceptisé où on vient en famille on
vient voir un spectacle où on ne
tolérera pas que quelqu'un se lève
devant soi on ne tolérera pas forcément
que quelqu'un utilise la corne de brume
dans les oreilles derrière et bien
évidemment qu'il a des fumigènes et puis
euh et puis des actes de violence donc
je crois que c'est pas aussi la volonté
de rechercher ce nouvel ce nouvel ce
nouveau modèle économique
euh la conséquence sera effectivement
aussi de de de nouvelles ambiances à
l'estades enfin je crois qu'il faut
enfit je sais pas si vous l'appréhendez
et si
aujourd'hui vous êtes vous êtes à même
de de le dire clairement aux gens parce
que je crois que c'est aussi une
nouvelle façon de vivre le stade une
nouvelle façon d'aller au stade une
nouvelle manière de voir le
sport en direct on passera vraiment de
de de ouais je crois de de d'une
activité sportive dans laquelle on est
acteur par par ces actes donc de de de
supporter à à véritablement un spectacle
sportif alors peut-être je ouais
suscitez peut-être vos réflexions
là-dessus euh à tous mais je crois que
c'est c'est c'est un élément important
qu'il faut
appréhender oui la question va
exactement dans le même sens c'est vrai
qu'il faut remplir les stades pour
remplir les stades c'est la performance
qui compte le spectacle mais il y a
aussi un élément les supporteurs et on
parlait de ça tout à l'heure de la
sécurité il y a de cela quelques années
j'avais une mission sur les supporteurs
on avait fait pas mal de préconisation
elles ne sont pas encore toutes retenues
pour essayer de faire en sorte que l'on
aille en famille tranquillement regarder
un spectacle regarder un match alors il
y avait un gros travail à réaliser par
les clubs hein puisque là ce weekend
dernier il y a eu un problème on sait où
à Nice le weekend d'avant c'était à
Saint-Étienne vous étiez concerné
monsieur le Président je crois qu'il y a
un gros travail à réaliser dans nos
clubs puisque bien entendu il semblerait
que certains clubs son amis dans la tête
de résoudre ce problème et que ma foi
c'est dans l'intérêt du développement de
ce sport merci alors peut-être je vais
je vais à mon tour aussi poser deux ou
trois petites
questions à l'ensemble de nos de nos
invités la première concerne
euh le problème de la redevance euh qui
est aujourd'hui
demander fixé dans certains clubs est-ce
que à vos yeux euh est-ce qu'il faudrait
pas fixer par la loi les modalités de de
calcul de la redevance parce qu'on a vu
une certaine disparité euh et et le
rapport de la Cour des comptes en en
fait mention de de certaines disparités
entre euh les différents stades donc là
aussi c'est question d'équité et de et
de
oui d'équité entre les différents clubs
donc à vos yeux sur ce point des
redevances est-ce qu'il faut que le
législateur se penche dessus et et
définisse par la loi donc un modèle de
de de calcul deuxème question
euh concernant
euh vos différentes expériences les uns
et les autres faut-il à vos yeux
désigner une collectivité pilote parce
que dans certains
opérations sent que c'est la ville
d'autres ça peut être la métropole
est-ce que les départements et les
régions ont participé à la discussion
parce que on voit bien qu'un stade comme
celui le futur projet de Lyon bien sûr
c'est la métropole mais je pense que
l'ambition aussi c'est de capter on voit
bien les les spectateurs qui viennent
au-delà de la métropole lyonnaise est-ce
que les les les autres collectivités ont
participé à ce type de discussion
département et régions est-ce qu'ils
sont
euh dans le futur preneur pour être les
les pilote et 3è 3è question euh on a
parlé du M à titre personnel je suis élu
d'un autre département qui a connu aussi
qui connaît aujourd'hui un stade un
équipement agronome qui euh qui est vide
et qui coûte cher à la collectivité au
contribuable c'est 1 mil00on et demi
d'euros chaque année qui est versé à la
collectivité aux gestionnaires parce
qu'il y a pas de club d'équipe référente
donc vous vous avez tout à l'heure dit
que le monde sportif doit changer
est-ce que ce changement qui est
aujourd'hui entamé par les clubs on voit
avec lon mais aussi d'autres clubs qui
commencent à y réfléchir par les privés
est-ce que les collectivités sont
associé à quel niveau sont associés
aussi dans cette réflexion pour changer
le modèle sportif parce qu'il faudrait
pas que les choses se fassent d'un côté
que les collectivités soient uniquement
sollicité à la fin de la réflexion
pour contribuer financièrement à
peut-être à à certaines opérations donc
est-ce que une démarche est faite auprès
de qui est-ce que CIT là au niveau du
ministère et autres que les choses
peuvent être un petit peu avancé voilà
ces trois trois questions alors je sais
pas qui veut
oui je veux bien sur la première
question sur la redevance je suis pas
forcément fan d'une de de de légiférer à
tout crain et tout le temps mais moi je
pense quand une collectivité
territoriale est face pour la la
construction d'un PPP en particulier à
un major du BTP qui connaît très bien
cela là elle est un peu démunie entre
nous je pense qu'il y a une forme de
déséquilibre entre les compétences du
major du BTP dont les juristes et les
techniciens sont extrêmement rompus à
cet exercice et puis la collectivité qui
est un petit peu plus démuni qui un peu
plus candide et oui je pense que pour
cette raison il ne serait pas absurde
qu'il y ait un cadre légal beaucoup plus
précis pour pour ces montages hein enfin
voilà les les les élus locaux c'est
naturel ne sont pas
on va dire des des des ultra
spécialistes et des juristes extrêmement
pointus sur l'ensemble de ces points ils
ont des service juridique certes enfin
bon soyons soyons concret il y a un
déséquilibre donc la loi peut aider à à
rééquilibrer les
choses monsieur caldera là al pour
répondre d'abord pour la sécurité et
asceptiser non je pense qu'il faut pas
asceptiser le spectacle puisque quelque
part il faut arrêter aussi de
stigmatiser le football sur les
incidents de quelques individus puisque
quelque part c'est c'est pas non plus
c'est pas non plus donner une image de
ce qui est en train d'être fait dans le
foot bien au contraire on le voit il y a
de plus en plus de familles après il y a
des il y a des supporters je pense que
c'est quand même quelque part l'ambiance
qu'on vient y vivre donc après en
fonction des des on va dire des
catégories de tribune vous pouvez avoir
des catégories de tribunes orienté
famille mais après celles qui sont
orientées comm nous c'est ce qu'on a mis
au point et ça fonctionne bien je pense
que sans le COP il y a pas de vie non
plus parce queil faut aussi qu'il y ait
des champs on le voit dès que dès que
dès qu'il y a une vie dans un stade
c'est quand même magnifique après à
l'inverse c'est clair que là c'est aussi
au législateur de nous aider quand on a
des problématiques de ce genre et de
vraiment punir ce qui doit être puni
parce que moi à côté de ça en plus je
suis directeur organisation et sécurité
pour le club donc on le voit quand on
fait des dépôts de plainte il faut qu'on
soit suivi vraiment pour que ça
aboutisse pour que à terme les ces
personnes se posent la question après ça
devient ça deviendra plus un spectacle
il faut aussi se dire que les nos
sponsors quand ils viennent aussi être
partenaire d'un club c'est à quelque
part aussi pour le les spectateurs qu'
viennent c'est pour cette foule c'est
c'est pour cette ambiance donc il faut
pas non plus asceptiser cette ambiance
ensuite concernant la deuxième question
concernant la redevance à l'inverse je
pense qu'il faut pas dire non plus que
les collectivités sont dé pourourvu de
conseil la seule problématique c'est
est-ce qu'il faut pas se poser la
question c'est le déséquilibre dans
certains modèles dans la même commune
puisqueaprès vous pouvez avoir aussi
bien une délégation de service public
avec les les les avantages et les
inconvénients de la délégation de
service public une autorisation
d'occuper le territoire comme on a au
Havre avec ses avantages mais ses
inconvénients peut-être plutôt à se
poser la question sur comment avoir un
modèle qui permettent de d'allier les
avantages de l'un et les et les
inconvénients de l'autre pour pouvoir
sortir quelque chose qui puisse garantir
un du moins garantir
une un appui des collectivités quand
quand quand il y a on va dire comme l'a
eu leement peut-être un écart pour
pouvoir les aider en amont je pense que
c'est c'est peut-être ce qu'il faudra se
poser comme question et enfin quand vous
parliez de de l'intégration je pense que
si il n'y a qu'une collectivité pilote
il en faut mais il faut que tout le
monde soit soit autour de la table
puisque je vais prendre la plus grosse
problématique à laquelle est confronté
on va dire tous les stades en France et
c'est pour ça quand j'aiécouté tout à
l'heure le président olas c'est vraiment
important c'est de se poser la question
des accès au stade et on sait que les
compétences sont diverses puisque quand
vous prenez un accès type puisqu'on fait
le parcours du client le parcours du
spectateur on s'amuse à le faire quand
vous prenez le parcours une fois vous
êtes sur la région une fois vous passez
sur la commune après vous repassez sur
la le département et il faut plutôt que
que tout le monde soit autour de la
table pour qu'on ait des accès et une
harmonie pour pouvoir arriver au stade
sans encombre et c'est notre
problématique et je sais que Nice a
aussi quelques petites probl problèmes
d'accès puisque quelque part après c'est
là où il faut qu'on travaille c'est sur
l'accessibilité de nos stades et c'est
vrai que moi je sais que nous
normalement on devrait avoir dans le
deuxème point dans un deuxième temps les
les transports en commun avec le le
tramway et je suis impatient qu'il
arrive puisque c'est vrai que nous on a
quelques problématiques à à sur l'accès
donc c'est vrai qu'il faut que tout le
monde soit autour de la
table bon sur le problème de la
réglementation je pense que c'est lié
exactement de la même manière au à la
réglementation sur la subvention
c'estàdire que à un moment donné chaque
collectivité avait la possibilité de
faire ce qu'il souhaitait en terme de
subventionnement des clubs sportifs et
puis il y a une loi qui est venue
réglementer de manière très très préc
c'est une une règle en fonction d'un
certain nombre de de critères donc je
pense que là aussi parce que si le prix
de location d'un stade est inférieur
dans un cas par rapport à un autre c'est
assimilé à une
aide d'État ou à une enfin je sais pas
subvention donc voilà donc c'est c'est
un problème de de subvention donc je
pense qu'il faudra effectivement le
l'assimiler en terme de d'analyse à ce à
ce typel voilà bon sur les autres sujets
je voulais simplement dire que les
problèmes de sécurité tels qu'ils sont
présenté dans les médias ne sont pas les
bons c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui il y a
une loi qui est une très bonne loi qui
donne la responsabilité de la
gestion des transports enfin des
transferts de de de supporters au club
qui prend la responsabilité de
l'organiser nous à Lyon on est
extrêmement organisé on est un peu comme
je dans une relation entre un comité
d'entreprise ses syndicats et une
direction avec nos supporters
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a ceux qui sont
élus qui ont la possibilité on les voit
une fois tous les trimestres on assume
complètement l'engagement de
transporter nos supporterirs dans les
stades verses c'est pour ça qu'à
Saint-Étienne il y a 15 jours il y a eu
un problème c'est que le ministre de
l'Intérieur a pris la décision de nous
interdire d'y aller alors qu'en fait
c'était pas lié aux supporters de Lon
c'était lié au fait que il y avait pas
de capacité de recevoir dans le stade
recevant c'est supporter là donc donc je
crois qu'il y a des lois qui sont bien
faites ce qu'il faut c'est les faire
appliquer et puis après bah il faut
effectivement dans les infrastructures
mais je crois que ça a été évoqué par
Damien là tout à l'heure bien tenir
compte de tout ceci mais aujourd'hui ça
n'est il n'y a rien d'inéluctable il y a
un certain nombre de phénomènes qui sont
intervenus parce que les groupes de
supporters n'étaient plus reconnus par
le club concerné et que on les a laissé
se déplacer ce qui
est anormal par rapport à la la
réglementation donc c'est pas une
décision des clubs c'est une décision du
ministère public qui aurait dû ministère
de l'Intérieur prendre cette disposition
là et bon j'ai demandé d'ailleurs à
Monsieur Vals une entrevue sur ce
sujet-là parce que je trouve que c'est
absolument étonnant de pouvoir dire des
choses comme cela a été dit au cours des
des trois dernières ou quatre dernières
semaines
oui très brièvement pour apporter des
réponses à à à ces question l'histoire
de la redevance et les questions que
vous posez sur la redevance elles ont
finalement commencé à Lyon
puisqueeffectivement c'est le stade de
l'Olympique Lyonnais bénéficié jusqu'à
2004 de la gratuité que Monsieur Raymond
bar s'était posé la question avait
demandé un avis au service des domaines
qui avait estimé laallocation à 1,1
million d'euros de l'époque donc de de
2000 et cette redevance a été calée à
600000 € par la collectivité locale en
2004 ou 2003 3 il y a eu donc un
contentieux qui a dit le droit ce qui a
fait effectivement les rapports de la
chambre régionale des comptes puis de la
Cour des comptes sur ces inégalités en
matière de redevance par rapport donc il
y a un besoin de réglementation ça nous
paraît évident pour que la règle du jeu
soit conforme notamment au droit
effectivement de de concurrence par
rapport au prix des investissements qui
ont été portés par les collectivités
locales et qu'il n'y ait pas et là c'est
un atout pour euh l'Olympique Lyonnais
qu'il n'y ait pas entre les vieux stades
déjà amortis et les nouveaux stades une
concurrence déloyale donc il pourra pas
dire que c'est toujours dans le même
sens il faudrait aussi regarder le
problème de la taxe sur les spectacles
parce que c'est la même problématique
qui se pose des clubs qui ont des taxes
sur les spectacles et d'autres qui n'en
ont pas faut savoir que quand on a mis
en place la redevance à la ville de Lyon
pour dédommager indirectement le club de
l'Olympique Lonis le maire de Lyon a
supprimé la taxe sur les spectacles donc
ce qui fait que le club n'a perdu pas un
un seul euro dans dans cette opération
est-ce qu'il faut une collectivité
pilote à à notre sens elle existe déjà
c'est soit les communes soit les
intercommunalité s'il y a eu un
transfert et un vote de transfert de la
compétence sportive ou de la compétence
sportive à caractère expectionnel moi je
pense que la législation est déjà bien
suffisante en région ronalpe
effectivement la région n'est pas
partenaire de l'Olympique Lyonnais et de
cette opération le conseil général et
partenairire la région ronalp par
rapport à sa politique ne soutient que
le stade de Saint-Étienne parce que
c'est pas est de même nature et c'est
pas la même chose deux dernière petite
remarque en ce qui concerne Grenoble me
semble-t-il oui Grenoble oui Grenoble
effectivement je pense que la première
analyse c'est que les les clubs qui qui
ne n'ont pas
d'assise d'assise effectivement montrit
qu' que c'était un mauvais choix qui
avait été contesté par pas mal d'élus et
notamment les écologistes tout le monde
se rappelle des écologistes suspendus
dans les arbres pardon oui parce qu'il y
avait des arbres aussi à défendre mais
mais il y avait une analyse qui était
globale en ce qui concerne l'histoire
grenobloise non non l'histoire était
était très très large mais donc Montre
Montre ça mais montre aussi que le le
débat qui peut y avoir c'est le problème
aussi des des partenaires étrangers là
il y a un moment faudra se poser la
réglementation des du partenariat
étranger qui n'est pas toujours aussi
sain qu' n'y paraît là il y avait des
Japonais qui sont partis immédiatement
là en ce qui
concerne les les j'allis dire les
sympathisants un peu trop exubérant des
clubs moi je pense que les intérêts sont
conjoints entre les clubs et et la
société pour qu'il y ait un apaisement
et donc je pense que la législation est
suffisante et qu'ils ont les moyens
effectivement on ne les empêchera pas
totalement mais c'est pas non plus
l'histoire la plus dramatique par
rapport au
club merci messieur il est 17h donc nous
allons conclure ce débat je vous
remercie beaucoup de votre présence et
votre participation n'hésitez pas les
uns et les autres à nous faire passer si
vous le souhaitez vos réflexions et des
propositions uni qui peuvent encore
venir alimenter le travail de de cette
commission et PU et peut-être que nous
aurons aussi l'occasion de de nouveau de
vous solliciter sur différents points
qui pourront être débattu dans d'autres
réunions de la mission qui sur
lesquelles nous souhaiterons avoir vos
vos éclairages merci beaucoup de votre
participation et bonne
soirée voilà vous avez pu suivre une
table ronde sur le modèle économique des
stades la suite de nos programmes dans
un
instant